ma i ragazzi buongiorno a tutti oh oh
finalmente siamo qui arpac hardback in
questa splendida live
mamma mia ragazzi mammamia da un po che
non facciamone pomeridiana da un netto
no lo chiedo come settimana niente ma il
pasticcio da un annetto ingaggiando
scusa ma perché le distanze temporali 9
tranquillo devo c'è problema come state
nagato tubini giorno la ramati non a
tutti i ragazzi che allora oggi faremo
un torneo su sky digis subscriber e
vediamo un po insomma come va
quindi io direi la di visto che abbiamo
tre orette buone oggi ente lorette buone
direi di entrare futuro avevano agito
nel vivo dell'azione nel vivo
dell'azione entriamo già nella partita
c'è partita
abbiamo il torneo innanzitutto vorrei
cambiarmi il nome che non i network di
gissi il bello come ti puoi chiamare se
questo è un ottimo quesito questo primo
casinò non saprei
l'a.d no no l'a.d
no non so come chiamarmi la caverò
davvero raga consigli in chat così
linciato sa che bisogna trovare già con
la lista carissima ok allora mo arrivo o
alla ragazza
faremo questo torneo tutti quanti quindi
se volete connettervi a partecipare o se
volete guardare
la nostra scelta comunque sia
prescindere se vuoi entrate sul vostro
rocket league e andate su torneo tornei
adesso ne creiamo uno ad hoc io l allora
non ci sei di io ci sono
allorché ok famiglia va un po di roba
qua per te
let's go allora vai io sono bello carico
e ha visti importanza ragioni e
tradimenti non me frega
l'a.ge ti ho chiesto buongiorno a tutti
i ragazzi
buongiorno my boys
allora dico ci sei ok mi è arrivato
adesso come sono arrivate sette perfetti
10 ok cercano arrivo
ciao pilot oria buon pomeriggio e ciao
l'ultima comin da giacomo allora gioca
tornei lingua
[Musica]
personalizzato corretto che ho torneo
allora faremo 22 il primo no e poi gli
altri abbiamo allora al meglio day 1 a
chi meglio degli 1 che vede gli 1 te ne
fai una brevità non ho che pensavo dava
il meglio di uno nel senso un gol
ok ora torna lo chiamiamo il torneo del
torneo torneo del torneo delle di ok
allora ci sta il terrore delle di tutto
peccato ora golden goal spareggio
pubblico europa rotazione non la visiti
ok tornato nei ragazzi ci siamo allora
il torneo delle di è però quanto ammesso
di partecipanti 128 va bene partecipa
partecipa al torneo
la la di squat ci chiamiamo ok conferma
top
raga quando volete basta entrare in
tornei e andate su il torneo dell di
dell'ebidta taggatura che non ci stava
fate partecipa 2 v2 e vediamo ora avete
cinque minuti per entrare e ragala fi in
me le luci e start e menez come estate
ragazzi intanto tutto bene è tutto a
posto e che cos'è lasko teca quanto è
bella la maglietta che ha preso
straordinaria infatti cioè non volevo
lori spogliarla family che al prossimo
matrimonio ci si veste così è esatto io
mi vesto con la mia di orlando ne va
bene una casa o poi arriva sino con
quelle facciamo a raga il torneo delle
di il torneo
il turn e il staccato torneo ha staccato
delle di tutto attaccato perché non ci
stava e le ho avuto mettono propagato
intanto fate
io mi mi destro e giovi mimì allen e joe
dovremmo fare un allenamento
comunque la cagata che non si possono
fare gli allenamenti insieme ai ragazzi
sono quando gli averi una partita
infatti non ha senso non ha senso sta
roba infatti dovrebbe essere standard
propria prova ad allenarmi anch'io dai
ragazzi siamo quasi ai 6 milioni ragazzi
scrivete vi chiedete a tutti i boys di
iscriversi i vostri amici vostra nonna
soprattutto è privati si devono
iscrivere per che arriveremo signore e
signori ha trovato pazzesco che li
ricordate la password non c'è la
password non c'è no la password non lo
so a meno che tu non abbia messo di
controllare per sicurezza ma
teoricamente non ci dovrebbe essere
anche perché a me l'ha fatta mette è no
allora non gioca in tornei non c'e
nessuna password possiamo vedere il tuo
torneo per una delle b
da torneo vediamo se riesco a vedere
tornerò no ok tra giornali a noi due 2
stata adattata trattata data il torneo
delle b24 128 non c'è nessuna password
infatti non c'è nessuna password raga no
password no penso e non l'ho messa lì
buttate dentro e lesioni due minuti e
cinquanta mancano il torneo delle
piccolo tranquilli magari ne faremo più
di uno ogni volta che perdiamo quindi
non più quindi ce ne sono tanti
anche perché non c'è un modo di spect
arechi chi rimane o si ha idea questa è
un'ottima doniamo io non lo farei
qualunque cosa no e vabbè ma per una rai
pomeridiana che facciamo io a giocare
tutta però si perde se la facessimo
torna in tutte le live tv ne dite però a
meno che non manchi l'ultima allora per
caso e comunque lo è veramente figo sta
roba qua di tornei a scoprire a saperlo
prima
se poi passa step faccia mentre anche
lui allora l'udc lo facevo in tre fra le
sue 12 v 2 e poi vediamo allora poi ci
sta anche un 3d proprio anti però nei
fatti profondo 1050 un minuto 57 esatto
niente di the bear dire le cose insieme
gli allarmi inizia ora pronto a fare un
paio di robe vorrei vedere se riesco a
fare una roba da dal muro
no io riesco a farla è roba dal muro vi
dovete facilissimo sai che io mi stavo
allenando su quello è difficilissimo sì
non riesco a staccarmi la luna prende la
palla
già morto lemonia tc incredibile bariste
chiuso max perché saranno accompagno vai
tranquillo noi siamo qua per un 3 orette
non loach e non riuscirò mai a fare sta
roba non mi sono mai allenato dovete
chiamare un compagno boys uno solo e
regala penso che è comunque che se siete
da soli vivi mezza con qualcun altro
quindi la farò mai a fare questa
violenza non l'ho mai fatta vabbè che
qua difficilissimo bra difficilissimo
devi darti sono poi un saltino dal muro
e ti devi girare subito con michael
analogico solo non col petto
io lo faccio con l'analogico però non
riesco proprio ad agganciare la pone al
macello se dopo difficilissima non ho
mai provato era ragazzino a dire questo
però avevo promesso che una prima sull
volare quando non ha mai provato però
boh jacopo welcome in the giacomo
possono ovviamente farne a meno lista
tecnica è però pian piano 30 secondi i
ragazzi sui bassi all'intera remo basta
entrare nell ottica
c'è poi una volta capisci come penso sia
abbastanza semplice e proprio solo però
minchia non avendolo mai fatto un
macello peggio che tradisce a portare
sul muro e cuore o fidati va bene muro
che a volte quel quello
bravo ad esse schizzata on the planet
che vado con la logica chiaro chiaro
pero gia partiti perdiamo niente 125
team di devo entrare con la pollica mai
chiaramente versus non siamo fra la
prima squadra si chiama non siamo
francesi
va bene maico come ingaggiato giacomi
col comico squadra contro di noi non
siamo francesi va bene si parte la dc
parte mi raccomando fu va bene in ansia
sono in ansia sono in ansia te lo dico
già tranquilli se tranquillo penso ci
siamo
sega righe a avremmo dovuto fare una
partita di test di prova potrebbe
potrebbe essere stata un abilità e vado
io vado io mai mamma mia che l'album my
boys torneo dei bros
oggi ci divertiamo un po molto cilla e
come cosa ho aperto la chat senza motivo
lanciate di testo mentre di lavoro vero
ma ma come quei problemi colombo come
già come brothers
grazie meglio è relativa mette in mezzo
come faceva come facevo come facevo però
non ha più un governo fa internet o
andare penso quello che no vado io vado
io no go gò gò gò senza turbo ci provo
paolo si sono tripla t1 che mai dire mai
beh beh io me e lui dovrà è venuto
allora importante ragazzi non è oggi
vincere ma divertirsi together
quindi state tranquilli se non siete
francesi già a partire bene col piede
giusto col piede giusto con le p e
corretto tutte le messe
ma dei laghi va bene ma come ho fatto
che la convince ad aladino lux il pinch
proprio lì quel punto un po così
madonna che cosa c'è ok molto buon
malato non è toccato a caldo caldo caldo
caldo calato ancora tutta aperta la
porta a porta alla porta ma trova da
nessuna parte la porta l'ha fatta la
parata da vengano turbo non posso far in
aiuto agli una ve lo possiamo più
tornare non è lunga la portava porta la
porta non trova la porta la porta a
porta ma boss vado io magari mattina
sulla porta la porta
ok a messa ma non ho capito bene ma
neanche io sono uscito il turbo si ti
entrano donna di oggi relativa preso il
palo
qui però oggi ti vedo carico è
abbastanza sono carichissimo abbastanza
carico giorno e notte non ho dormito non
ho parlato con i miei genitori così ai
fatti solo questo ma stai giocando prima
no no no
ormai spiazzato bene non ho preso lascia
di no non è vero vai tranquillo e lui e
vorrei fare una roba che non mi riuscirà
mai però ci provo e che costa e lasko
teca e lasko tech a pirene vescovi de
giacomo gara grazie il mancio si intende
un action back era carino e molto
sembrato librario band hero anche anche
gli avversari sportivi a era presa lui e
niente nulla
che brutta roba
ok non sono stupido la mancata proprio
bene
maledizione la porterà vuoto l'ho
buttato avanti a casa tutti all import
aragon canzone di madonna tutte cioè non
ho assolutamente turbo infatti non
segnano mai vediamo vediamo se riesco a
fare niente si sono uscito per niente
scusa di corniglio ecco ecco ecco ecco
ecco non è vero
madonna è stata toccata ma don niente
toglie di chiamo prenderò un qualcosina
farci da due ore e un papà mamma vuole
abbastanza inutile questo in realtà lo
stesso fatto
va bene io niente erano curvo e nessuno
può guardare ebbe sognare mamma mia ora
come fa sognare tutti però non avevo
voglia fare nulla l'avevo sprecando
tutto tutta la in the mezzo bravo e
niente
ciccio 01 mio mer come ti chiami grazie
aveva come in the giacomo caro nonno
turbo non so perché non è la per farseli
lavoravano preso l'oro era una valuta
indietro e nulla forse allora siamo in
mezzo io non ho capito che cazzo di fine
ha fatto il turno perché ho io ero
andato con convinto di averlo non so
proprio come è successo
va bene diamo mai ho trovato io
in the mezzo
alessia televisore spoleto national bank
svuotamento giancarlo volo ricordarvi
ragazzi a francesco pecca scusami
l'avevo visto e anche in a bulino gabri
va dato vinta e giacomo ma erano persi
due torri adesso leggo che ne sono a
migliaia di now e adesso fatemi dire
fare una roba un attimo ed una pausa e
tagliate e niente allora devi fare ci
devi mettere un po di errori dovrebbero
essere le 11 ma annuncia ma non solo
lavorativo da molti modi questa signora
sensi sul pavimento
ok è un macello
cioè non se non lo sai fare veramente ma
certamente perché abbiamo preso come se
fosse sul pavimento processo il muro
cioè se in aria voglio dire quindi è
veramente un casino però figo
diciamo che piede a terra sono marci
belle la di toglie non è gol però da che
possiamo ripartire non da solo non mai
curva una mia regola gol e gol e gol
le cose e con le cose giuseppe mattia
ragazzi nuovi ragazzi
insomma ci fa in una teca bravissima
sono veramente un idiota
no era veramente facile
bellissimo molto
scusate ma no finché lo sentivo a patto
che non parliamo con la adesso è che
quanto sopra di due perché avete un
gioco va bene è la prima si fa le
prescelte che nome certo di salute
grazie chiaro interpreta il debre scelte
veramente un nome incredibile ragazzi
rom 2 abbiamo allora che ci sono ancora
sotto la perché le altre volte non
lavoro letti sono un pirla da un 2 ron
398 quarti finale semifinale e finale ma
però non c'erano un'altra volta michael
stich l organo
vabbè innamorata di morata una corsa
innamorata limonata cosa che gli scorso
dalla chat che queste pena lievita asia
grazie ad un action stavo molto bene
grazie mille
voglio vedere se si vedeva la roba dei
tornei
ecco allora vediamo contro chi siamo
adesso
adesso siamo contro i soft i so se una
donna un casino che hanno battuto non si
sa chi usa che stava per partire
ecco niente non ho fatto in tempo a
leggere comunque c'era un bel po di team
ragazzi quanti siamo a sabato che i
fratelli stiamo 125 tm dovremmo essere
va bene se no ritirarla avanti per
cercare il più possibile di un percorso
che si dedicano tranquilli pedinava
un'altra buca prescindere andiamo
risparmiamo tornei questo pomeriggio
pratico e rosari ex ma come indagato ma
allora the next one
madonna troppo naturalmente troppo
quello che non volevo fare soldi soldi
stampato fortissimo ma non volevo fare
niente youtube
va bene
attenzione la tira solo ma che non
sbaglia utilizza l'errore avversario
dell'esperienza anche io vado io vado di
categoria questo è l'inferno guarda già
ferma
[Musica]
ma dai sono mai viste e bun patu sarebbe
stato gol perché poi non era dritto no
tranquilli la teca della gi oh mamma
mamma mia mamma mi era stato calcolato
garko lazio tutto calcolato
mamma mia pg vado io vado io
i
pen by non ci sono tranquillo
e sbagliato va da sé che è veramente
abbiamo rischiato di fare un gol
pazzesco è sì sì perché io comunque ero
lì in agguato come il vero coccodrillo
mammamia questo te lo lascio tutto mamma
volumi a mamma mia
però un po di vantaggio raga come che
dice leo giocatore spaziale
termoelettriche di 5.000 di elia
riguarda la guarda la guarderà mamma mia
che precisione la mammina ormai sei mesi
il carico tra il blocco sarà da bloccare
una cazzata no sono un pirla e dal
dribbling no scusami non era buona ma
sono giocarcela credo un po cile west
ham sarà una balzano subito la guardia a
guardiola ace 3 mar
l'aifa più alto mamma mia che gol di
robben o palo interno
lasciamo la mente sono arrivato ma è
bello che sono arrivato anche bello
deciso è per niente la palla vive
davanti alla porta avversaria si è sulla
linea ma non vuole entrare sopra grande
effettivamente non è che sto tirando
meno serio e li ferma da due ore
facciamo un 4 e poi siamo un po più
cilla vai vai se lo facciamo magari si
accendono un ed attenzione già questo
era goloso era gol all esatto ci hanno
usato toni si nota la seconda teca della
d
però come non importa noi consigli non
importa non lo so per certo che è
successo più netto il caso dagli
indietro non solo 49 il tiro no liscio
totale arriva l'amico l'amico non è il
liscio e bravissimo di che libera e caos
ecco io mamma mia non ho quale l'altro
la risatina malefica dell'arte lo
pulisce niente sono tali ma è giusto
così è giusto così perché il karma
qualche gol
no però male al coperto lo specchio
bravo hai per fatto la risatina malefica
ma la sorpresa il cap ranzi no no non so
chi non ci sono ditte di toglierla oggi
sono proprio morto ma non è vero ti
guarda ricche controllo la metterò più
mezzi uno più non solo con la porta
ed è proprio un retroscena entrato
guarda che brutta cosa le tane studio è
andato talmente avanti ha detto no ma
come si va dai tempi di caro
mi si è alzato il rateo di rocket di
vittoria al 59 per cento prima 58.9 quel
59 mi rende se fossi se sé ma perché
arrivare al 60 ci vorrebbe un miracolo
sarebbe veramente più che top
avete visto questo è le statistiche puoi
vedere esiste ma tutte queste
statistiche molto molto fanny riesco a
fare lo stacco dal muro evitano ho fatto
un qualcosina riesco a non ridevo io sai
cosa devo fare
devo capire bene come si muove come si
come roteare la macchina in volo perché
molti li assegnano un altro tasto io
utilizzandolo tasto standard non riesco
c'è un chiaro che c'è un modo molto easy
però non c'è molto in modo più visi
cominciando però io utilizzo i comandi
proprio base quindi secondo me c'è
qualcosa c'è qualcosa chambray fare un
approfondimento con vari tutorial ma ci
sono un sacco di roba da modificare che
uno magari non ha mai fatto strapazza
segnalare signora che non ha mai la nave
di share considerazione ma ciò la sola
cobb la zona morta del controllato da
una volta le cose hanno capito neanche
cos'è ma non lo so il mio controller mi
sa che è morto tutto è morto un maggior
controllo però la zona portale scusa dei
figuracce
prov
va bene
da quadrato le risposte a delle una vedi
vedi ma sai che mi troverei veramente
scomodo però se io ho capito quello che
stai dicendo avrebbe più senso del freno
a mano è certo perché quello è il modo
per roteare in aria capito a ok sono
solo di fare un passaggio col dito che
non ti viene normali non normale fare la
zona morta e quando la levetta non va se
non la spingi fino a dove l'ha impostata
dal centro ma pensa te ho capito ho
capito c'è il cannes broschi il clan
broschi contro chi siamo adesso fammi
vedere ora stiamo aspettando due team
che si chiamano le pale le apette lord
taylor migliore
il mio colore 101 quindi se finisce fra
un minuto penso piazza accipicchia
bellissima chips vediamo un po come sta
andando coniuge rory do bellissimo la
strage di nomi dei team ragazzi coniuge
roar idolo visto chi o cosa più bella è
giusto broschi luca sei per me a numero
uno
quanto fa a via più b la seconda wow oh
wow ricercato dice wal mart ex lug ozzy
i fogli i forti top va bene porti
veramente andare effettivamente hanno
vinto tutte le partite che ignora sono
forti si sono forti attenzione partita
in style è partita
il coccodrillo per il momento è rimasto
sempre sempre in agguato ma non ha
ancora mai attaccato no ragano fa alla
seconda via la seconda tra ve lo
assicuro legge visto partire tra tra
laghi e tutto ti ho visto che sono stai
negando potrebbe essere un problema
io non l'ho che non vogliono certo
quando inizia la partita con il set
vinti da quel che la grana turbo manco
per sbaglio io avrò d'acqua bene peccato
questa cosa ha preso bravissimo no sono
un po oggi proprio non c'è rispetto al
100 sono in decima
giuro ma sono veramente un idiota rublev
atto perché lo controllata così male
mammamia tra quello nerazzurro queste
gol questo è tutto per la di l'ho
toccata ma non era facile per come l'ho
messo io e roberto tira tira una teca
non importa grazie per il consiglio di
cori e niente però comunque devo mettere
in pratica cose non me la chiudono
niente parola tirare una teca eccolo
niente dai telemetria nemmeno la sia
infestando la mira sta aggiustando
un'amica che fai vai vai ma che forse
era bellissimo non ho seguito
ritirare bye bye bye bye ma papà ma la
madonna ma come gioco ma perché è
stregato la mia testa non lo fare
tutt'altro che questo è stregata questa
porta e maledetta maledetti stato un
giro abbiamo fatto come possibile solo
tm niente entrare c'è un campo di
formare ai no ma cosa ma quanto volato
storto
no frate mai capito pazzesco perché tipo
sei gol quest ora niente no imbarazzata
ragazzi imbarazzando la ragazza sono
scioccati giuro non so che dire se ne
vedono ci sono creato scioccato è checa
chiavelli e parata è preparatissima
entra da loro certo da noi sono gravi
no perché normale lezione la dico
non era male e mezzo sì forse un po
troppo bravo ma non so neanch'io come
non è servito anzi ora bravissimo capace
in quel palo interno era bruttissimo e
ragazzi sto capendo se andare dai miei
natale per questa situazione spero di sì
ovviamente almeno macchina poi vedremo
comunque posto proprio vedendo in questi
giorni vediamo che si riesce a fare ca
ma siamo ancora a zero ma com'è
possibile non so avremmo fatto 190 tiri
del gioco ce n'è da tre incredibile ok
da mentana questa me ne andavo
e lei catechista marco le donne ci siamo
1 a 0 abbiamo fatto non lo so abbiamo
vissuto di là grazie federica
occhio
è rimasto bene ma so che lì ci sarà
vasco lentisco legato al joystick non si
è dimesso si è dimesso a vorrei fare lo
sportivo è fatto bene mamma mia quanto
questa cosa anche sportivo sportivissima
sportivissimo no però comunque aveva
ripreso il joystick in mano cioè voglio
dire ha mosso le scale sono io è con
tutta colpa mia di scusami ai gol
eh si io sono stato stupido sono andato
sulla palla completamente a caso c'è
senza un motivo
questo quale era veramente evitabile ho
fatto tutto quello che non si doveva
fare farli più che altro che sfiga un
tiro dai in giro hanno fatto tutto in
nero ma è normale sono partito fascista
non so perché così impazza la partita
brutta
bravo barone e squadra comunque che
stiamo diventando è però si sta ormai ci
formiamo molto gravosi va beh mica fuori
giocare insieme
vai vai vado io
ho pianto perché la stavo così lega
finale
eh vabbè strafatto proprio tirati il
don't worry ormai per me ma finirà
questa cosa prima o poi non penso con
bbc come l'insufficienza di elettronica
soldi ma è normale ho fatto infatti
andare fuori tempo perché pato fuori
tempo io amo
va bene va bene va bene va bene domani
prigione e onesta la discorsi porta
grandi squad ragazzi ottimo oggi un
professore donation caro anche boris
mostrare uno ma se mica booster è uno
piuttosto riuscito a buttare r1 mi
ammazzo brutto effettivamente le 131 non
servono a niente giusto e non lo per la
chat lordo però non metterei mai io per
adesso il busto r1
certo mi ammazzo allora quindi adesso
uno tra fell cioè legale e le sue
caselle se va bene minuti e 30 ancora
che di over booster è un aiuto regia my
mind queste recenti ma io non ho mai
change atto quindi non potrei dire per
me se io metto il bus 31 smette di gioco
c'è un figlio non c'è più ho finito per
me di giocare e poi è tutta la questione
di abitudine che l'aver no chiaro però
attualmente
ragazzi il torneo adesso è già star dato
quindi non potete più partecipare ma non
temete perché tanto da p fino alle 18 ne
faremo parecchi quindi se siete
veramente easing che è piuttosto
scegliete già un vostro compagno per un
appunto per giocare insieme per
partecipare al torneo e poi quando
sappiamo il secondo trinate easy proprio
impartiti helm alter meter
grazie mille a donation paniz grazie
mattia grazie mille ragazzi ci sia ma un
certo momento però il mio proprio e la
mia volta vado io me la fai ti possa
imparare il live drible fratello prima
in cui poi quadri vari quando io vado io
vai vai spara fasciati sulla palla
rimane libero telegraph ne rimane
importano st importa a noi a forza ok ho
fatto un po di pressing sezionato col
palo gol
io avevo fatto lavoro di pressing è
eccezionale con
l'attaccante attivare che poi è andato
via desolato francesco chiedi al book
silone nazionale i settaggi del pad
ma francesco hai ragione il discorso non
è quello io lo so che questi tasti che
mi stanno dicendo sono quelli lo so già
che sono quelli che si utilizzano a
livello di progaming e sono io che ho
una paura finale nel cambiarli di
posizione capito ci sono io proprio mii
carriere gli addosso perché è un po come
siti come sempre guidato la macchina e
sul volante lo mettiamo il sedile
posteriore è un ragazzo che c'è nel
senso
poi magari piano piano ti pigli però
all'inizio di parola strano ma vedo e
che storia incredibile blu e penso che
non lo so davvero bravo ha sbagliato
tutto
caduto controllarla va bene e questa è
buona per lotti e non sbaglia una sede
dove passare tutto sbagliato dovevo
stare in difesa tram pd tranquilli
la mossa gioco loro mi raccomando perché
qua se perdiamo siamo fuori a niente
niente questa qua non merita di essere
lì sul baiano tutto sto facendo niente
di avvitamento in aria sbagliati ci sta
ci sta bene sbagliando tutto
ci sta qui st padalino ragazzina le 18
oggi fino alle 18
vado più più più madonna
vai tra tagli e tagli la j
amos realtà continua veramente uscì
osceno perché da come l'ho presa
malissimo ci mise proprio accartocciata
anche alla mani va bene però
guardate che entri però simona arletti
sembra solido national direi che grazie
anche a te caro terra che malfoy
mamma mia c'era c'era
toglie non andare però se decidessi
imitarla statuari dottore è andata anche
dall'alta per fortuna che ho coperto lo
sa mai turbo devi togliere la lira che
adesso riparte ok va bene che cosa stava
facendo
perché visto un po il cavolo fatto cioè
cosa in aria ci sta claudio è questo
sottile una bega no star italia bravo
vai tira lascia
io non ho assolutamente turbo ma mai
proprio sbaglio tutto sbagliato tutto
controllo inutile beh va bene ma allora
fa ci facciamo che giochi tu non so ma
che cazzo si faceva il nome ragazzi oggi
sono per veloce è quel che sta facendo
tutto fatto sono togli la taylor tolta
taglia toni ha tagliato via provavo
onesto vado io vai tu e tutti allora che
non ho assolutamente turbo
vabbè prestini cioè roberto carlos
occhio che tirano nesso ok togli la
togli la toglie
per far ripartire vai vai vai vai
no sono veramente stupido perché l'ho
fatto così forte era colpa sono babbo
sono ma sono tutte cose che tu noi che
non dovresti sbagliare invece stai
sbagliando lorenzo visto probabilmente
se lo ha fatto non ci credo
ok perché l'ho fatto così forte clicca e
tranquillo l'uomo sbagliato di ade
punisce la pincha sul muro aspetta
l'occasione vince nella petrillo cattivo
la terra ci vorrà di chi i cattivi ma i
pallini vado anche io vado lì e ferma
guarda indomita incognita anziché
tramite la sentito solo nell'intero
listino di occhio che tira meglio pure
ok va beh qualcuno l'ha pare che per
cento
anche loro distrutto su ragazzi veri non
mi odierà tantissimo o no ti pasca ma
vediamo allora bravo io non ho niente
madonna ma da questo tirano noto come
par aria cielo invece mantiene sotto
niente bravissimo la di mamma mia vita
cosi bravo madonna no perché ho tirato
così brancher mercà perché famosi nero
toglierla perché nessuno e in parte no
minchia male no sono stupido stupido
dire di toglierla
ti prego cavani poi
bene va bene scusami procollo no no no
rimborsato anche storta grande di palo
ma guarda che rimbalzo è poi infatti già
papà massimo
volevo fare robe che non ho fatto te lo
assicuro di no
niente ricchissima va bene anche come
neanche quello anno finisce sto finisce
partite così per chi non può smettere di
buono buono da terminale di è dai bravi
quarti di paul agon e e l'attrice e
dario grazie a the nation simona anche
ciao favino si carica il sito della fed
a ragazzi manutenzione da mesi purtroppo
ci ho provato a sbloccarlo ma dicono che
a domenico sblocchiamo dove non
sblocchiamo ancora non si sblocca a
inizio del a gennaio se non si è ancora
sbloccato fango non facciamo qualcosa
ragazzi a notti fa vedere i tornei che
hai fatto
ok vedo to di one step diciamo allora
fosse un torneo del genere adesso capito
allora allora rimangono 38 team giusta
quanto pare di tanzi 38 team in partita
molto bene molto bene
la chat vocale su rocket una volta si
attivava con l 1 cioè con quello r1 r1
r1 mista di sesso non so se si attiva
ancora funzionano non la uso non ce lo
dà mai ma ti mangia come prova ungaro in
be giacomo ma di come si allena a volare
ma per non sta fermo ecco la barricata
benvenuti ragazzi ricorda una gara che
sono state allestiti al canale magari
con altri con il vostro secondo oppure
se avete un amico che non potrà calare
il titolo perché siamo quasi ai sex meo
è ormai brother semmai six million io
nel momento di arrivare a 6 milioni
ragazzi fate parte dei 5 milioni prima
che arriviamo a 6
questa d'azienda da zero
madonna o più tranche allenamento sono
traversa
niente c'è veramente guarda e credibile
adesso capisci cosa provo io niente
entrare non filtrato e strappato elo
soldi mi sono sentito ti compravi ton in
testa oppure chissà magari fosse solo
uno di è quello il brutto attenzione
sono passati siamo contro l'europeo 0 15
let's groove leo pio 15 e basta lo 0 me
lo sono inventato ma non c'era anche lo
zero non c'è si parte è il diamante sei
adesso attualmente mi ricordo se sono
già ti amo mi chiamassi l'amico adesso
andiamo a 32 diamante tre capelli
trapiantati non mi ricordo più
se mi sono rilanciato diamante tra no
con stef
non mi ricordo non mi ricordo più no
forse sono ancora di 22 ordinanze di
reintegro ma la sil king e leo p
ma vera leo di massi king's i ragazzi
hanno vinto e perso 2 1 contro l'altro
tipo ro
e niente di cio tutto che brutta ma a
patrasso vai
non si faccia carico di vita di là di
ogni modo gravissimo
ho anche tenuto al ragazzo sceglierà
tantissimo vabbè dovevo farlo parlare ma
ci arriviamo uguale light crude vado io
mai quando riesco più a parlare
no io niente mia 1 ragazzi oggi niente
niente niente proprio niente tutto
sbagliata è sono stupido era da fare
questo era da fare
ok di ska bravo ma domanda ai pressing
c'hai il prezzo sempre die burger
hai un ottimo pressing il portiere di a
lui no va bene ancora meglio della
difesa di ancora più meglio della difesa
era più meglio del debito
cross in mezzo non poteva essere noi tre
dietro un pc hanno chiesto e ballo
finale
bravo
evviva la barba una toccata scusami ci
sta ci sta
non ho video noi lo tormenta l'amico
niente ma molto statuto standard ma
niente suonato gli accordi andiamo ai
tool anzi
madonna
e
la bellissima non ho niente da mette in
mezzo cavo occhio che parto
no no no tutte completamente di cura di
loro pendono amore ormai è stupido
figurati se allora prendono un palo
comunque non ho certo e bay ma ci sta
solo quattro partite ci sta ci sta che
non ci accompagna anche la fortuna ha
sbagliato niente male
e va beh meno male perché altrimenti non
avrei mai presa mai proprio mai presa
mai mai presa mai cenno va bene un
normale questo è non era male perché
rischiamo il male no sì alla prova 1
niente o forse si può ora che dentro
lavora chi entra non sono stupida o no
potevo fare un po di meglio il
pallonetto sul pallone ok va bene ma
cosa ho fatto per in corso
vai vai vai vai niente un po
no mamma mia che partita di per partito
preso malissimo secondo me
a
tutte cose da fare e non farne la mamma
mia dai dati clamorosa vai tu vai tu
gravissimo ancora bravissimo che gol
ok ok un minuto 30 mio finora ho
sbagliato tutto tutto sbagliato tutto
ciò è veramente non so se è un tabù ieri
poi non ho fatto niente di giusto cioè
fatto tantissimi errori che ovviamente
potrà evitare di farmi occhio vai
non ho turbo ma mezzo mette in mezzo un
peccato cosa ha tolto questo occhio che
ti fa il si scavalca vogliamo e non
potevi sono perche non potevo fare
niente perché se andavo sulla palla
segnavo io guarda quello schivata
all'ultimo perché ho detto minchia senso
per finita
dai dai dai cavolo ma bellissimo
niente realtà ha fatto anche il tiro in
porta ma bravissimo però io l'ho saltato
vuoto praticamente un numero male
e sì sì sì che babbo 30 secondi a buy
eni si chiamava grande arco ragazzi non
c'è e ci cosa ce ne so io e ci se ne sa
ci torna dai dai cazzo fa la mia
macchina
nel mezzo da meno è l'unica a prati al
volo dice niente l'anticipato cg dai
tgtg
peccato peccato era fegato ma era fatto
e abbiamo giocato di merito però vabbè
bravi ci sta ci sta
quarti 66 guardi ci sta correndo
correndo
vabbè dai ma vedrai next one era
mostrato che è durato un sacco anzi
molto più di tutti gli altri è dipendere
cominceranno le partite si comunque
verità ci sta ci sta a quarti di finale
ragazzi la prima l'abbiamo fatta gigi lo
stesso gigi lo stesso peccato perché si
poteva fare molto meglio
però oggi un po così ragazzi subito lo
facciamo il prossimo torneo sono sempre
la nato one si torna e si arriva a secco
a siamo tre perché consiste fa abbiamo
qualche possibilità in più tutti bene
dipende allora ok il torneo delle il
torneo bello che lavoro il torneo bello
bello bello
it's time for the new torneo let's go il
torneo bello the next 2 minuti e 35 a
partire da adesso che avete un commento
hanno trovato in tempo a trovarlo a
svegliarlo da lì a citofonare a casa
distruggiamo tranquilli il torneo be
alone presidente esecutivo che c'è un 3
tornei
la signora era un torneo e durano per
forza devo fare le cloud 2 sono platino
3 quasi diamante immeritatissimo se
posso dire però a cagare
non è vero se impara che siviglia lato
tanti deve per forza perché se cioè il
migliorato sono migliorato però comunque
andiamo allora che sia quello giusto
dice io mi fido di te la senti molto
latino tre si sono registrati sì platino
il miur latino 3
anche considerando il fatto che comunque
come spiegava stesso la scorsa volta i
ranks un attimino tipo slittati no e
perché più che slittati perché non ho
dubbi hanno proprio modificati non
voteranno di avere un'altra c'è la
stella blu cioè non avevano proprio i
nomi diamante se non erro c'è il platano
ecco perché ho visto qualcuno con la
vincitore torneo stella blu ho detto ma
che cavolo è stella blu e latino
adesso per una volta la stella blu mi
pare fosse diamante cioè da anche di una
volta erano totalmente diversi non c'è
passo ragazzi non c'è password
totalmente freud
ebbene roma ti confronto all'inizio si
sono migliorato però comunque è la teca
e michele amiche non ci sono problemi
dai non ci sono problemi ma figurati ora
ultimamente se poi c'è la differenza
sono perché mi fa diventare rosso faccio
diventare matto
non c'è la password ragazzi zero
password quindi totalmente nuova entrate
si chiama torneo bello allora vediamo un
po ci ho provato a fare la vita mentre è
vero che comunque è vero e benissimo il
fatto che se tu non non sposti i tasti
cioè fare certe cose è impossibile
perchè rischia ci devi usare un dito per
fare due cose film in un play off se
fisicamente non poi però mi chiamo
riuscire mai a spostare i tasti adesso
ma è come su corde che ai pro gamer
giocano con
con un setup completamente diverso da
quello per esempio con il quale
giocavamo noi tu vedessi come giocano
come tengono le mani sul pad
se siamo solo noi ma che cazzo fai gen
e allora tipo il l'indice lo usano tool
sul sui simbolini del pe del padre vito
sulla parte destra e premono le r1 e
delle due con il medio
si no beh è una roba incredibile
incredibile totale l'ora e c
grazie al web vende già con my brother
the keys omaggio
o per dirla
ragazzi avete ancora due minuti e 20 per
partecipare al torneo anche se mi sono
accorto adesso che è full quindi in
realtà non potete fare a niente
non potete più partecipate la faremo un
altro robaldo perdiamo la prima di
pensare a perdiamo subito altro torneo
sicura e con quanto sia fortunati due
minuti e le carta degas ho tirato come
si fa la vita mente da pat e devi
premere il tasto della retro del freno a
mano e poi ruotare in aria però questa
cosa qua la puoi fare solo ed
esclusivamente se no filata puoi fare
comunque però diciamo che consigliato
farlo se cambia la posizione dei tasti
io lo sto facendo con i tasti settati
normali ed è un suicidio
proprio un suicidio
io sono che non c'è più iniziato a
tremare ci stiamo khalfan calcando sotto
mica 10
comunque la città secondo me è
sottovalutata sottovalutatissimo
facilitare ci stiamo pagando noi dovendo
vecchia vi i francesi e ci stiamo
il francese francese in francese si dice
invece a caen
potrebbe darsi se li lozza mcqueen e
giacomo bystrica can't stop sotto e ne
sa più di di tedesco tipo non lo so
madonna
36 secondi ragazzi si scalda s7 lori
best dei somari come in the giacomo lo
slow ski on the sun news e non so niente
di prenderlo fa pensa io facevo francese
alle medie
non ho mai c'è partita è stata la
francese è stata la prima materia che io
ho fatto nella mia vita dove sono volati
dove volevano i due brividi ai tempi
c'erano non sufficiente e era la presa
che poi dalle superiori in poi iniziano
le materie dove tutta la classe a due
triple e l'ironica di voi per fare un
nome a caso per fare una nuova casa
elettronica elettronica elettronica
chimica nell'elettronica di nokia fisica
dove non una persona a 2
tutti hanno due parla quindi c'è un
evidente problema didattico che non è
nostro è la prima volta in cui la mia
esperienza di vita scolastica dove tutti
me compresa avevano due quindi non
sufficiente
era con francese francese alle medie
tutti del seicento terrifico che non
sufficiente la facevamo mercato sapevano
che prendevo con quale personale media
per passare una bella ora goliardica in
allegria con la classe ma infatti c'era
divertente ora che contro il peso o due
ho due grandi laghi diamo uno forse
fermo e allora niente non segno se
ripeto non mancare ma è niente lascia
giocare da solo la dei va bene se non si
muove facciamo un po di firefly
e che cos'è la ascolta e casta macchino
distrutto magari si schiera attivino
accorto del fatto che sta giocando
no sono meno viva joystick tipo io l'ho
passata dai più importa ma niente sì
sono felice siamo nazioni a testa dai
la avvitamento su se stesso
lui ne sa cambiamo che avrebbero e
niente
giochiamo 1 contro due la dei non
sbaglia e beh è un duo sì ma un po
particolare questo pati è un 1 marx
layer esatto è un po particolare
poi tutti i troni i denti sovraesporre
donation grazie toni grazie caro è
partito chi è questo anche col seno
tonico
no non è quanto era bello quel periodo
te lo ricordi ne parlavano solo così si
è stato un periodo della nostra vita
problemi ci al 20 stava mutando la voce
esatto
magari un evidente la scuola siamo noi
perché lascia stare oggi a scuola mi
hanno fatto veramente arrabbiare ma chi
è questo angolo di la settimana da dio e
pero uguale scusate se aveva volato tivo
giuliana vasi bellissimo se allora c'è
quel periodo di vita dove tu parli e di
tisi fanti 20 vengono fuori gli sbalzi
di voce il bilancio deputate marina si
sentono vivo ti convoca iniziano a
parlare così però non riesce a farlo
cioè è difficilissimo farlo ma la
compagna dalle slayer e bros e sbaglia
niente è morto è posto subito pensati ti
risvegli dopo un sonno così profonde ti
trovi il latte la green baciano la n
young a me va bene penso io non ho
chiesto e che cos'è e lasko teca e che
cos'è
traversa
io andrei cillo comunque non finisce più
non c'è youtube fatti è fermo per
territo
e poi mi aspettavo di turbo pa pa pa 122
realtà come adesso ma c'è chi non ha
fatto niente mica se me lo scarta vuoi
di retromarcia non vedevo niente joga
bonito però vediamo un attimo prima
volta mancava era la ripa seganti ha
distrutto
joga bonito alla ma nessuno ma nessuno
parla
come vi importa master appariamo e basta
gli importa faremo le basi ci sono i
portieri se quartiere tutti e due ma
importa visto proprio simbolo dritto fra
ti sia porta prova ma vi sembra mai
visto il porto visto che la porta la
porta l'ha portata a portopalo dalla
tarda nota quali fuori tutto calcolato
ai ragazzi non attacchiamo noi attaccati
voi ragazzi venite chi ha una portata
mela morta in centro come meno falli
almeno almeno in porta ragazzi non avete
pressing ragionate su quello che dovete
fare ancora non ci siamo
è un passaggio amoroso da collage al
meglio forze antinazionali attenzione
guarda lo guardano come lui si sa invece
che gol contro la state aveva pregato
perché non pesa rivas e l'altro io sono
stato fermo ha visto dopo è arrivato
bellissimo bellissimo
e vabbè due figli si vede che ci fanno
sette gol sete adesso su cui c'era
esattezza se non grand champion non solo
smesso di gelato
da cava e lasko teca questa è una grande
discoteca
[Risate]
no vista rischiato tantissimo ma
tantissimo cosa sta succedendo ma
vediamo come prosegue l'azione
attenzione prova il pallonetto contro il
muro controlla da solo
prova il tiro mezza scoreggia prova
l'altro tiro completa scorregge niente
da fare
questo un gran torneo ovunque sono i
migliori abbiamo scelto ragazzi del
corsetto testa buonasera
niente dai ragazzi e dai ragazzi dai now
is the time of lunch va bene niente
forse una delle partite più combattute
la linea che sarà un partito delle live
va bene va bene siamo al sound 2 the
next it's good siamo contro i fari gay
attenzione tentano così di trigger armi
dove sono dove sono ci sono anzi quattro
su quattro con gerò lido attenzione
riesce a con gerò rido era nell'altro
torneo c'è anche qua i pesci stipe
scisti cosa vuol dire pesci stimolo di
crescita una cosa non sono
professionisti li hanno presi dalla
strada che sta questa è la è una vera
cit cresta che sta questa ancora che
ancora più meglio della che ancora più
meglio dell'altra shift non so presi li
hanno presi dalla strada
penso male
la cia
soldi è colpa mia perché perché lascia
ma non ero così pronto
meno male liscio clamoroso di ragazza
accompagnata da dio accompagnata da dio
accompagnata da dei tanti non l'hanno
presa
questa qua è una città penso sia la
migliore di tutti gli altri ogni già
comincia ce ne sono di alto giovanile ce
ne sono veramente tante a questa secondo
me li hanno presi la nostra è una delle
mie preferite dato quando li ho visti a
dal vivo è stato incredibile è passato
un sacco di tempo
mamma è un trio comico che gli avrei un
sacco voglia di vedere dal vivo ma hanno
fatto un sacco di teatro loro era
infatti mi sa che la prossima volta
due giorni vai tranquillo si lascia
andrò a vederlo
non so se fanno ma la mania bel gol ride
non si fanno un bar di e mezza e
speriamo una volta finito tutto spero di
sì perché altrimenti me lo sono perso
cioè me li sono persi proprio non ho mai
visto è anch'io perché poi chiaramente
tutti i vari magari ne faranno un
corvino ma io magari ne faranno ancora
uno per uno
speriamo
sbagliato nola nel ragazzo tantissimo
camera questa la gam bloccati tutti
niente tutto fermo torneo bloccato ma
che successi sarà dirò che sono esplosi
io non sto vedendo niente con tutti
fermi e poi se avessero la palla se si è
bloccato tutto il torneo
beh no non ho capito effettivamente che
cosa sia successo non ho veramente
ideano cosa è successo uscita dato a
connessioni gioco è scaduta quindi mai
fatto tornar melo principale no beh
c'era in partita io ci sono ancora
dentro il campo che sto correndo come un
pazzo e adesso mi è uscita una inattesa
dell'avversario che cazzo vuol dire beh
forse mi ha fatto uscire anche a me
adesso non hanno capito la nostra è
scaduta è andato secondo me sta
esplodendo loket livio ceco vi serve
stanno andando o magari loro hanno
guidato magari non ho la via che c'entra
la finta e non lo so magari boh non lo
so ragazzi altri altri tipo che stanno
partecipando neo variamo acquistato
perché stavano perdendo
non lo so non ho idea però non penso che
succeda questo se perdi e quindi strada
vinto non l'idea ragazze altri che
stanno partecipando al torneo sai cosa
stia succedendo sanno cosa sta
succedendo
supersimo vinte giacomo mai bruschi
aspettiamo ancora tipo 2 minuti anzi si
sblocca se noi facciamo un'altra capito
che avevo detto strano
c'è qualcuno nel torneo che sta giocando
la gara si è alzato a chi ha la pseudo
knicks posto io tornavo da costa non lo
per la epic no e qui sono più data vinta
automaticamente appunto quindi no
secondo me c'è stato un primo giro vi
serve dirò che sono esplosi prove mi
stavo giocando nel torneo solo a bo e
non ho capito io sono uscito senza fare
niente
adesso adesso mi dà cinque minuti anche
a me adesso o cinque minuti è
praticamente che cavolo vuol dire che ne
sono
riparte il torneo vediamo magari la
devono giocare o forse adesso si
riassesta c'è una data che strano eh no
perché a noi ce l'ha data vinta e frate
come fa a vederlo è perché nel tabellone
siamo siamo passati noi magari lo vedi
forse matera scusami tu sei uscito poi
ha reso la sangio camera giocare la
stanno giocando le ultime barche stanno
giocando si vede che praticamente sono
andati al free server e nel mentre la
partita è rimasta 2 a 0 capito potrebbe
da quindi raccontata come 2 2 a 0 è
lanciata da vinta vediamo se le solo da
5 passa 4 minuti vediamo sto guardando
solo in alto a destra ragazzo vedere
quel numerino diventi si abbassa vuol
dire che a posto ma si stanno giocando
di apple e tre allora a posizionare
siano i partiti
niente ragazzi ha avuto un
una botta al server non so dirvi una
défaillance una dei server ansa ad esser
vero zaiana odiano galbiati ma è
qualcuno che ha mai chiamato daiana di
cognome però la prof di inglese e non mi
ricordo io lo guardavo sempre in maniera
basi chiamava tajana mi chiamava tajana
mi diceva non scusatemi mi sono confusa
daiana a caiano ti ricordo il periodo in
cui la facciamo come fa rosa come
dimenticarlo penso che la di ne abbia
ceas è stato l'uomo in grado di farvi
perdere la pazienza
c'è di più in tutto penso che come
allora come lui nessuno ragazzi dovete
capire che su fifa cosa giochiamo
insieme tutti quanti specialmente quando
gioca a led con l'altro nostrani tardi
quando l'altro storico di fa gol
praticamente c'è un gol che si chiama
golfo che praticamente la mia l'ho
chiamato maio stato l'ad che quando
semplicemente passi la palla in mezzo e
segni facile non c'è perché la lega
andrà quella terra su di te il bagno è
il compagno easy lab torna vuota col
fuffo profughi riprendo quando si fa
quel fumo contro nichi che lo odia
davvero tanti signori gara e di borgo di
scarpe è il nostro amico quando mi fa il
golfo incomincia a correre per tutta la
casa urlando prima sempre il simbolo di
pazzini tra i signori ci ha visto dove
stanno anche nelle foto di quando
giocava a calcio cioè delle foto che
segnava con così pazzini pazzo pazzini
il pazzo pazzini nell'est
ecco il punto ragazzi sa però che non
c'è il foglio cioè se poi chiusura che
si può fare se ti può fare ma non c'è il
portiere fisso quindi per minuti tutto
questo tre minuti i ragazzi comunque
sono io babbo giorno ma voglio giocare
le punizioni su fifa
ogni anno diventa sempre più di facce
che non l'hanno lasciato quelle normali
una volta che erano perfette erano
precise erano bellissime tiravi proprio
come cacchio volevi adesso ha dovuto
mettere suo cerchio di merda che non si
capart e che non sei da vero oggetto se
non lo tieni non si capisce niente se
non tieni pure perché anche io tipo dei
rigori lo metto a destra non troppo a
destra è ora tira in mezzo la tira fuori
buio era capisce niente
ogni anno fifa diventa sempre più
difficile è la difesa però la difesa ha
poi giocato al 2021
sì va beh quello non rendere possibile
non sapete rendere ci pensa ma navigato
e sentito il casino che è successo a me
gol con ibrahimovic
no non ho sentito che si è lamentato che
è su fifa che non gli andava sentito no
c'è un casino ultimamente perché dicono
che non hanno i diritti di mettere i
giocatori tutti i pali mettono casinò
sta succedendo
cioè se state leggendo in giro lo sapevo
no no no allora io sapevo tipo per
esempio la juve non ha dato i diritti e
no però il giocatore mi pare un'idea da
lì proprio l giocatori non lo sapevano
la storia ma infatti mi sono io mi sono
sempre chiesto mai chissà come fanno ad
avere i diritti tutte le persone forse
non cediamo a me lo chiedono alla
squadra e lo chiederanno alla squadra
però tipo che ne sono ad esempio la è
però dipenderà dal tipo la juve non gli
dà ok è esatto e ci hanno detto perché è
stranamente non pagano non solo ne so
nulla e poi ho solo letto cose
neanche la roma ai diritti non sapevo
neanche la roma ma in realtà non lo so
la lupa si chiamerà roma senza essere
però ma roma è la città o lazio che
hanno lazio non si può chiamare lazio
calcio si può chiaramente calcio invece
la lazio calcio è il calcio e cento
piemonte pietro pizzo se non li dava
editi neanche ti amo te l'ho chiamata
bagna cauda calcio sanitarie quello boia
faus fc boia false feci bellissima aviv
un egocentrico myroma fc si chiama ha
visto perforza però non te ne accorgi
neanche perché roma che io non me io che
non su un cazzo di calcio non è
d'accordo piemonte me ne accorgo
piemonte calcio da calcio nati ma anche
un attimo strambino ma neanche in tipano
ma non ci siamo
attenzione dopo due ore questo vi parte
mamma mia che non ho capito che mi sia
data vinta dai primi 20 sinceramente
siamo ancora dentro la mossa non so
magari hanno avuto loro problemi di
connessione non lo so non credo secondo
me ha avuto problemi con tutto rocker
che anche l'altra non era partita se
tipo questa dipartita dopo è vero è vero
vediamo il team
non si gioca così gioca un moto di
attesa per i giocatori ma non c'è un
tavolino è il personale 5 di dire la mia
testa dei giocatori un minuto dai che ha
le palle o attenzione uno stand travo ha
tentato anche se vuoi giocare il bahrain
sono emozionato
dobbiamo aspettare comunque 50 secondi
no
mike è entrato scivolati volava e dei no
no no no no no perché ok non andava non
andava uno studio perché è brutto che il
suo campo cioè particolare al nome di a
me piace tantissimo invece il mio
preferito salti shore si mi pare non
sono state sempre uguale no eh vabbè se
voglio fare una roba la gente della mia
porta per spazzarla non riesca ai turbo
che me lo meritavo tolto
sbagliato gli togli la vedo io è troppo
foto però bravissimo o l'a.d
a me piace tantissimo stati shorts e
particolare dai la cosa bella è che
prende il colore no il colore dei kim è
aperto più bello a me piace questo caso
di sabbia dal una foto bellissima mi
sono piaciuto il mio preferito ma porca
trottola essendo chiamata per andare al
trucco novo di scartarlo devo dire che
cose lasko teca è un feeling ma che
schifo
guai a prima volevo spazzata così porta
andato a metà campo adesso invece che
vuole forte non s'è mossa è bravo ma non
fa male
no la mancata con un bisogno lascia
lasciato lascia tutto lascia tutto il a
brunate ga incredibile con un idiota o
sbagliato tutto volevo fare una cosa poi
ho cambiato idea nel mentre che la stavo
facendo ho fatto una cazzata mondiale
volevo perché ho guardato lui ho fatto
una cazzata volo controllarla in aria
hanno fatto tutt'altro
una via di mezzo che non si arriva a
niente vai buona buona è il bravissimo
fa tutto da solo ma di tutto da solo
tutti i campi prendono al corriere tv
uniti di come sia effettivamente vero
forse mi lamento poteva che prendono il
si prende un allora secolo dc no a
quella linea in mezzo prendono al colore
anche quella se come diceva quello là di
se la prendono solo colori i bordi ma
comunque a me non piace per quello che
capisce proprio perché più bella tutto
cos'è successo cose che succedono robe
ma in mezzo ci sono e non ci sono state
molto bravi se la volevano fare come
cacchio me l'hanno presa e hanno
camminato con la cascina ma come cacchio
faccia a parare con la fed cup che
rischio non è vero ho sbagliato i
calcoli c'era il menù del gatto che si
fa i calcoli poi salta storto dice volo
sbagliato tutto quello che c'era nella
mia testa ho fatto diverse e niente
niente niente oggi proprio 0 0 non ho
capito non so non andare andare a me non
va bene buona di accompagnarla ma stavo
presso presso niente mi deve superare
però posso puzzle altro apple in un
pezzo del bacalà e lascia vai vai non è
bastata nono turbo buono la palla dove
si sono spesso saltati tutti tutti erano
turbo per tornare loro c'erano sicuro
bravissimo
quando diventerà poi cambiare colore ah
sì effettivamente vero potremo cambiare
il colore però vabbè mi hai notato che
il campo prende il n ai bordi si tutti
invece del club quando giochi con il
club ovviamente di liscio però qua
prende anche proprio in mezzo a capri
sono stelline che prendono il colore del
20 non macello niente ho sbagliato con
l'orco no no no no allora adesso sempre
di no adesso tutti io come faccio a
prevedere il futuro esatto come fai a
prevedere il futuro cioè perché parliamo
allora cosa è successo guarda cosa è
successo cioè tu lo sapevi tu lo sapevi
credibile è perché ho sbagliato in
genere quando faccio un errore grave in
gioco di punisce capita dai che abbiamo
pulito anche loro ma abbiamo pulito
la di che prevede cose paranormal a di
team hartmann mattia che volete
nomination caro perché se si abbassa
bene queste clamorosa bravo bravo bravo
bravo patron sera era terribile come
deve essere
ha avuto sfiga dai paranormal la di
vamos lo rilegge le carte senza le carte
vado io minchia ma come impossibile
bravo è solo uno davanti c'è solo per
dire ma non sbagliare e briefing
breaking fi ma non ho un turno per
tornare indietro la di cioccio io bene
dov'è
va bene non era per niente volevo fare
niente diamo
vai vai a letto la morosa fida solo
paolo 10 insieme non prova che tra in
mezzo forte di niente
spero perché era un po dietro forse però
la donna ve lo tenete ad arcate non c'è
minchia si è alzato un utile di per un
spiazza tutti la di note g comunque
anche a me hanno cresciuto il server nel
torneo che ai più è mai ha avuto prove
rocket league è un problema di server e
ne
grazie maestro grazie quanto non ho
visto quanto non l'ho visto il tabellone
vediamo non ho visto neanche io la disco
della di squat abbiamo ora un 4 abbiamo
passato forse siamo ai quarti di finale
no no siamo rom 4 ancora siamo contro
l'ex game 05 ok per avatar e quali no
questi erano il team
questi erano la partita che avevamo
fatto che poi avevamo vinto ricordi nomi
dei team
mandiamo avanti quindi quarti giusto ci
sta contando tutto e non ce la fate di
iniziare
no no no no no non le scopro vado io
flash games ha giocato con flash player
problema 9 attenzione morbidissima se
non prende questa comincia a diventare
matto si no sorry no no
oddio
devo toccarla però perché se non sicuri
o demolito lui non la palla parti che
non si può divenire la palla per ok la
gente
scusami fra non mangiare una volta
controllo non fa per me diciamo dai e
invece materia dell'ati che se ne scatta
1 si scalda anche secondo la tv
bravissimo gravissimo mamma mia
guardali guardali che cosa ha fatto il
giorno a casa sei matto matto comincia a
diventare mamma
buono sia perché lo stortissimo no ho
sbagliato è tutto qualsiasi condono non
esiste questa è la canzone che una
guerra che stanno ancora ma ho fatto una
roba che non aveva un senso neanche di
limbo niente niente come ha fatto questo
ragazza lo si può cioè tuscia non ha
sbagliato
beh allora non so fare nulla non so fare
nulla niente tutto bene goldoni per
coach e saggista ancora meritato perché
come cazzo sto giocando lo so io cosa ho
fatto guardalinee di sori il socio da
tutta la fascia
bene
10 cubo io
bene bene
lì
ed è giusto che sia il gol no non è gol
però strano perché eravate vuol dire gol
sempre cioè la palla deve entrare tipo
curva tipo quando c'è il gioco del
calore l'articolo cercato di calore
quello che curva la palla in porta
cioè se fate all'errore grave che fai la
palla prende una piega lì la turbo mai
io neanche fatti fatto stack agata ma
sto calcolato
ma la mia mano male dai dai dai
penitenti allora segnatevi far insegnare
vi riportiamo ok quali vai vai vai
massimo famiglia
la bici se riuscisse a tenere palla a
terra un secondo senza essere disturbati
dietro ok senato gli
meno male meno male
vai via via che doveva scuse basi volo
per il bello perché non la prendevo bene
da lì capito di sinistra è niente gol
io non posso come 93 di solo di
prenderla di prenderla oggi mi
raccomando da impegniamoci veniamo ai
fatti non siamo semplicemente facendo
nulla
stiamo giocando di merda vamos mai nulla
prova a calci in quella foto troppo bene
va bene niente tutto come non deve
andare dai 45 secondi i lati ce la
facciamo
e si sa nulla
peccato ma in mezzo dice che tiro ma i
viola
no però guarda meritiamo tutto questo
punto sì sì meritiamo tutto non è
entrato nulla mi ha fatto 2000 tsi non
entra niente
dai dai dai dai prova ancora
niente sbagliato io 16 secondi e la
super fatti mille gol fattibili ma ad
aiutarmi e mezzo di
no ci sta ci sta un senso festa era
veramente bella bravissima potevamo
assegnarle tutte queste raramente bello
l'unica volta che abbiamo fatto oggi ci
sta bravi bravi ragazzi bravi ci abbiamo
fatto veramente ridere ma qualsiasi cosa
per ora però non ci sta ci sta ci sta
chi ci vorrebbe la parata finale si per
la parata finale che la loro dieta va
bene allora the next one ragazzi
questo dato un po meno lavorativa di
minuti sempre 22 come vuoi tu però per
me ma per ora la parola per ora ok per
ora è ok allora fini non è sceso bravi
il torneo snello prova dico subito a
riposarti e vai tranquillo la di
scommettiamo cambiare i colori ragazzi
allora mettiamoci grigio o bianco o
bianco o nero
poi non so se solo bianco a strisce nere
o nero strisce bianche per la città di
madagascar ma domani a madagascar che
bello che era che bello ricordate lega
va bene cercate il torneo ragazzi e free
oggi ragazzi food tornei senza password
entrate entrate
eh no ma infatti era bellissima cascata
cioè che ti ricordi incredibili il torre
il tono ragazzi sia il torneo snello lo
vedete in alto a destra ma sa che
madagascar e io ho visto solo il primo
cena ho visto mi pare anche il secondo
ma così a alla veloce
ragazzi la fenech lo show pata tipo mese
fa ormai note passato ma forse non un
mese fa ma più o meno
è lo so che anche gli altri sono
meritano ragazzi sapete però non ho mai
non so come dirvi non mi hanno mai preso
tanto seguiti delle cose anche tipo
dell'era glaciale bellissimo avere
lasciato ricordi di nicchia di mamma mia
che abbiamo il pupazzetto di non si
chiama paolo ii che stava dietro la la
cosa la ghianda scrat bravo il
pupazzetto di scrat ma gigante bella
bellissima gara mi guadagni punti è
bello era scrap bellissimo stop
il mio personaggio preferito e la rivale
cioè perché un po mi rappresenta cioè tu
che fai una cosa succede disastro esatto
esatto beneficino di andare il terreno
una cella ed esplode tutto esatto così
stupendo il pupazzone è un po grosso è
stato alto ma che contro un metro
poi dopo di quando finiamo alle 18
fermati un attimo di di co2 robe
ah ah ah ah lo scoiattolo in camera
prendavamo ragazzi era bellissima c'è di
che parliamo
sognavo con qualcosa di veramente carino
highway due minuti e 12 lega per partire
vediamo se siamo già full in tutto
questo non lo so nicola un gioco bruges
1 stavo dicendo non ho sciupato il pass
perché il par
no aspetta non mi ricordo se non si è
occupato il pass ed al pascolo o quello
che ho comprato al limite
purtroppo subito perché da un po che non
prendono niente quindi a mykonos e l'ho
comprato man rocket pass nozze
boh non lo so sì l'ho preso
se non mi darebbe ste robe fino a che
livello per arrivare fino al 90 comunque
figo che il passo è retroattivo cioè tu
fai la partita poi sciocche e poi ti dà
tutolo che non ti ha dato in tutto sto
periodo per i panni di civili di
esperienza e seguite da cinque parate o
per atleti che nelle partite online
allora io mi sto bevendo un bel
caffettino caffé tè giarty di caffè tè
giocosi e in quest ora dobbiamo non
guardare al poso non scherzi però le
capre entrare adesso è un c'è
impossibile perché già fule il torneo
dovete essere pronti dove the sniper
aree il torneo appena finiamo quello lì
in corso appena vediamo quello in corso
creiamo subito l'altro vi diciamo il
nome lo sniper a te entrate easy
lui l'ha fatto stavo vedendo
effettivamente che ci sono un sacco di
tutorial per per fare lei drible
dribbling e gol di casa e io penso che
nei prossimi giorni mi ci dedico e lo
capiamo per bene perché secondo me si
può fare solo per capire e solo a capire
come si fa
c'è anche se mi dice che ci ha messo
poco e solo proprio che da capire i
tasti che bisogna premere si fa è un po
commenti poi ho provato a insegnare a
grazie a fare a fa volare sul rocket
dopo un ateo riuscito perché proprio da
capire solo il meccanismo ci vorrà
qualche sbaglio proprio come la partenza
devo riuscire a girarmi devo girarmi
subito non dopo
solo che accetta più o meno un po
rugginoso però ci sta già partendo milan
si parte le scopo di lamon barbin
l'ascom pari
l'hamburger set ci siamo se va bene
allora dario pronta e des bois taken ma
capisco perché il nome della squadra è
sempre un nome di uno è vero che hanno
scelto qua sai che ti faccio un predict
bello grande va perdiamo la prima
scommetti dire no no no io non scommetto
ma perché so che è così certo so che se
ti senti una cosa è quella io lo so
ormai io ho imparato e invece e invece è
realtà spero sempre che non sia così
chiaramente tutto da solo tutto da solo
che bel colore che hayden e la macchina
veramente ma che anche tu mi sa o messo
bianco alcune partite nero nelle altre
da lì è partita la città di madagascar
sono bianco a strisce e nero nello
strisce bianco a 0 ma non è vero ho
perso il timing
buona ne va bene con la figlia
occhio che tira
ecco mammaria nella mano è nulla
totalmente sbagliato io dico mappe dai
partiti 29
non voglio rivederlo non voglio
rivederlo
non voglio rivedere niente anzi vorrei
cosa di men in black per potremmo anche
diventi queste gol
bello no peccato
tira bravo di dj gigi
è stato fortissimo
niente ho dato tutto
vai qui mezzo non è vero no scherzavo
questo dario questo per info
no scusa di niente perché è stato un
cassino abbiano proprio di monte milito
ma no io ho dovuto qualcuno attenzione
poi voleva buona buona non avevo cioè
era un bordello direzionarsi ai trials
l'ho presa
beh è l'ultimo bellissimo ha funzionato
veramente una cosa ha funzionato davvero
che sovrano è frutto di città che tac
brave che crea mi era quella che
comunque pare comunque ride vai tu vai
tu vai tu come cazzola che apre solo fa
saluto a voi cari un bacino che stiamo
dicendo no sta tecnica del passaggio se
fatta bene e ledro e letale cioè letale
nel senso che vale più degli altri in
volgare più di tutti se tu sei passato
ti sai passare la palla tra compagni
questa cosa non ha paragone a livello di
utilità cioè ma prendi non è la nel modo
migliore per x terran care perché non
capiscono più niente però il problema è
che è difficilissimo fare da fare poi a
livelli alti se la passano anche in volo
per farti capire però no devine sorelle
clip
ho visto gente contro di me che se la
sapeva passare da dio cioè sono persone
che trovi in
in normal con fortissima io sono chiesto
ma perché giocano bel gol del gol a
toglierla trip i miei predict sono
amorosi modo io chiamo
sì sì sì sì sì un po via
ok abbiamo due gol così abbiamo preso ok
non sai cosa volevo fare
cartellino rosso fuoco tutto quanto per
gesù quindi potevo fare una rovesciata
in volo c'era un 6 ospitata la durata e
la vizio e era un desk del giro pagato
dalla rai onyx per fare i soldi ed è ciò
che fa segnare pasta segnare erotico
poveri quelli che ci siamo presi dai
e allora materazzi è caduto però perché
ha preso una testata la testa taglie la
data lesina dean e zinedine zidane
quant'altro mi fa morire l'accento con i
colleghi ci sta cosa e dove l'espresso
lo so penso molto raffinato da oggi
volevo fare la trappeto è niente tra
peta della di gente tra tra pedoni
va bene ragazzi la madonna che dire fa e
ora parla di scusa ma questo dovevo
farlo
mamma mia si teneri gasato ci sta quando
si casalesi tutto spicca successiva si
deve sfogare il tentativo loro
attenzione incredibile lettera a fare
era di dice di no dice no perché sono un
po di ansia cifra attorno
sei un casino immagini questo dario a
questo dario e pure forte 15 tentate una
missione sul favino ma niente sbagliarci
ogni problema se non stia facendo il
paio e vito disegnare le tavole sono
dura tanto noi che facciamo le palle
pagliacciate no non è per prendere la
prima parlavo di me anche questo
dichiaro concluso il dibattito tra me e
lo so che ho scritto niente
karin del nero rosso fuoco tutto quanto
per l'assiduo non partire vediamo se sei
inserisce a pararlo aveva visto se
tirare una torta memorabile
va bene va bene andiamo a prossima pensa
se fai tutto la scalata di in finale
dopo aventis fatto in quello guardo e le
trovi una strada di tipo così magari
quando arriva al fondo di una world
esatto che il vicolo campionato 10 chi
sono io sempre
cioè non ti sicuro non è un altro ieri
nord in paura dopo 15 anni che non
vinciamo una world on
mammamia l'emozione non puoi capire un
bellissimo poi c'è il bello fan con i
francesi che abbiamo di socio di soci di
pirla e pirlo 6 x 3 paloschi uno che ti
invia edificio bene taro si chiama a a
giro giunto a roma ma lei tutto questo
pesa la di contro i de andré de andré
ti prego voglio vederla rock italiano
real e juve sinistra può essere caterino
rosso fuoco tutto quanto birthday giu
materazzi è caduto perché ha preso una
testata
stiamo partendo ed il momento battello
momento della next del next next next
gen
ok giocano uno da pc all'altro la play
15 g di tu davanti ok go
va
ma chi è questo è stato anche sfiga per
loro poveracci
diciamo che poteva essere evitata qua
qua andata di spiega perché era saltato
verso la direzione della palla quando io
sia rimasta per i master ed a chi
controlla sul muro se ho sbagliato tutto
ho sbagliato tutto
in mezzo la guarda guarda questa è la
perfetta bronze che dopo perfetta ma in
un certo senso che cito con noi dice
simone
a mio
la g io non volevo fare assolutamente
questo è niente de andrè è veramente
fantastico che mi piace troppo il nome
ma stasera fatto apposta ma questo è
venuto un gol non bastano gli arrivati
siamo stati in linea siamo saltati non
potevano non entrare questa palla ma
scusami cliente niente guardando se mi
aveva scritto perché stavo cerca di
capire chi è che aveva suonato però non
mi ha scritto nessuno di voi un corriere
magari e non lo so
qui si si si si
e domenica scusa medicazione consegno la
consegna lo consegnano corriere no no ma
non è il momento il girone non lo so non
avremo anche la storia intagliatori a
tornatore
lasciamo poi vai vai
non è uscito il flick mannaggia
ogni volta che provo non mi riesce a un
rosi è addormentato un ragazzo ci
addormentate ma anche il mio film sia
tormentato siamo pari ho cliccato a
vuoto mannaia che si è risvegliato mamma
mia che finch ata della dear god bella
ho fatto lo gnorri e stavo uscendo e non
sarei meritato lo sarei meritato
in che senso è fatto lo è non ho saldato
dato si fa aveva anche per l'altra volta
è uscita la paga sia partita sulla luna
tipo golf no domenica ragazzi consegnano
ve lo posso garantire perché days con in
arabo mi è arrivato in arabo come in
arabo prato io ho ordinato degli slogan
è arrivato in arabo si pazzo ho visto la
confezione detto va bene dai aperta è
iniziato ciò che cancelli le protese
prelato aveva quindi sa che non capisco
un cazzo non si è riusciti altro ho
detto magari lo metto dentro una console
sei anni fa scaricare non so il
pacchetto multi lingue cioè non lo so
qualcosa invece no gli rimane in arabo
massimo inglese l'ho detto siccome sono
due ma veramente lei sì ma perché ma che
essa ha detto siccome sono 200 ore di
gameplay sele paio ma era questo il
citofono posso far vedere questa cosa ti
prego
adesso mi arrivare se ti faccio vedere
lo vedrei dall'allarme arrivato simone
così ti prego
prego perché è arrivato un simone questo
video con guarda guarda guarda aspetta
che siamo nati prof
grazie a sostenere una collega mangiamo
insieme questa cosa va bene ok va bene
dite che si vuole dare ai ragazzi simone
si sia esattamente simone è free quindi
se volete un ragazzo eccoci ma porta
anche le crepe ma che volete di più è
che col 6 lasko teca cioè nostro capendo
grazie simon gli sono cagato sotto
pensava fosse uscito di casa ha detto mi
chiamano le chiavi del gioco ha pagato
il pranzo
cioè non so ma è un supereroe si muove
mandato ha mandato nella terra sulla
terra per aiutare noi no
allora dopo c'è la pausa dina cresco
prima dell'ultima tornata l cosina crepe
rispondiamo a domande mamma mia se
sapessi giocare a questo gioco si è
visto un gran gol e si vogliono e non
solo non so driblare non so parlare non
c'entra fare attenzione dati pero lui sì
lui sì se la vogliono normo faccio andò
avanti per inerzia bella questa cosa che
ho fatto
mamma mia cartellino rosso tutto quanto
ben di giu materazzi è caduto perché ha
preso una testata alla testata gliel'ha
data e zinedine zidane in e zidane
ma il gol
questo se avessi saputo giocare questo
ho detto io saprei sa qualcosa
no no no perché mi sarebbe venuto un
ictus immagino anche a me quindi ancora
qua quindi nel messaggio tutto ok siamo
ancora tutti e due vivi quindi
io comunque sono riuscito a sbagliare
questa cosa porta vuota per fortuna l'ha
messa lui
dovremmo smettere si è infatti smetterla
di sì facciamo basta basta col disegnare
sennò è un ragazzo ha scritto porca
trota che gol però non so di che
consiste parla porca trota a uno dei due
sicuramente non nei nostri stava
guardando un hub e scompiglio tra live
poi mi mara tonico danno al nostro bravo
questo mi ha fatto un bel pallone
pericoloso malati dice dino tra entrando
che stava entrando importa tutto usa
ripropone i retro propulsori lo va a
disturbare ci stiamo fermi va beh sì è
vero
mario leone thank you for the nation jet
in romandia landi grazie mille ragazzi
non si deve voletto male di lei bene non
so quanto tempo abbiamo perché li
vendevano parte largo la 6a praticamente
un sorcino attestato di 339 la prova che
michelle mi ha servito meraviglioso
maraviglioso maraviglioso un po di
energia
peggio ancora 22 sta impazzando stasera
sarà il caldo non altro la prossima
settimana non so se anche tu hai visto
le previsioni del tempo ma dovrebbe
nevicare fare
in teoria torino dovrebbe nevicare
questo vuol dire che finirò the witcher
3 days con tutti i weekend ricette ho
iniziato da qui ci altre veramente bello
sai più se mai giocato tutto iniziò
giorno tutorial bene che è più o meno
comunque lungo quanto la campagna di un
call of duty infatti perché non l'ho
finito è questo
mamma mia un ragazzo finito territoriale
quindi ho detto è però se io giocarsi lo
giocarsi sicuramente mi piacerebbe
vicino è bellissimo
tira
adesso
lgs la prendeva stavo malissimo perché
guarda che dà proprio sotto al seven mix
legal f
a che cosa doveva essere scattato due
crepe e un muffin alla nutella come ma
posso mangiare
mamma mia tu sia posto per due anni io
mangio fino a dopodomani e non è stato
fatto di s
ho parlato io qua cos'è un deciso un
dibattito solito da quello che girava
sembra non ci sono
madonna è non sono uscito a togliermi
provato in tutti i modi piatti da dire
ancora la ancora la io ero tornato in
difesa perché non so perché avevo visto
la freccetta traccia accesa la precetta
svampa tornano turbo da in mezzo e vale
no avrei dato tutto tutto tutto tutto
tutto tutto tutto tutto tutto tutto
tutto tutto
tutto bello visto tutto tutto tutto
allora
un nostro sì come escono come sono
questi ragazzi si si si si si come no
lo guardavo ii e guardalo li lorenzo me
come leggiamo ungaro mezzo menchini
degli so much
meno male che ci sono arrivato perché
questo aveva un bel missile non ho modo
ne andiamo
vai tranquillo e tranquillo 20 casi
mou se ci avessi creduto ho creduto io
ci avrei creduto
facciamo invece avrebbero creduto cia
prossimo che l'ultimo a prestito esatto
se ci avessi musso lo credi terry ma
nessuno
non si va si parte bravo
eva maiga nascita fare nulla
allora com'è potuto accadere guarda 40
sun times a cannes
ma bensì sindici palo palo gol ok
comunque mai fatto 3 gol in tutto questo
spiderman mais morales ragazzi io l'ho
cioè non lo volevo portare tutto il
gameplay volevo portare solo una parte
perché non faccio generale dei nono
turno di fare provo ma bravo no peccato
e io ho portato solo l'incipit l'incipit
ha mai portato che è raro che io porti
gameplay
lei purtroppo four cross non è che non
sia roba horror niente non suscita
toglie per molto meno male dal
commissario o vai tu hai tutto
piatto no
boh io tira addio è sbagliato non
finisce mai stati un problema
vai vai vero uno turbo ai don't even i
bonus metsos provoco il salto normale è
mai
era meglio quando portava i giochi ora
ora pensa solo ai soldi silvio però
laccato di vito hai con la persona
stessi dicendo kate invece che ictus
titus e basta
oddio è che come niente la squadra che
l'ha presa nel testo è andato io glielo
messa giusta per chi la roma a campolato
cosa l'italia ci siamo siamo dissociati
dalla partita non certo non giochiamo
sia veneto va bene dai
mangio che abbiamo una compagnia di voli
aerei non si gioca la di dati come
possiamo chiamare una compagnia di voli
aerei pro la di airlines capisco niente
allora abbiamo un minuto hanno un minuto
e 35 per fare quattro gol è possibile
quota plan
allora signori il momento di finire
questa partita palo un minuto dai
mammamia meno male variazione proprio
scarso comunque colto ma don fuori
no ma perché comunque sono molto
autocritico dire quindi cioè mi rendo
conto di fare ma le cagate a volte che è
impazzito ragazzo
e
va beh beh beh ti mette la firma
trovando vincitori torneo al diamond lor
la di earl hines e pilota chi tutti e
due pilota copilota e filote con i voti
dei fatti e insieme ad essi voci più
note si porta le crepe ma regala entrato
papa dovremo entrare
meno male perché sono finiva più picchia
è però non abbiamo abbiamo risolto
niente perché non si corre mai il tempo
separata tra l'altro ma che a chi ha
fatto un cappellino rosso fuoco tutto
quanto perdi tu materane è caduto perché
preso una testa non tirano anziano di
finisce domani
ebbene tutto bene che lo chiedo niente
se mi devono segnalo qui no la ti dice
di no cioè che non lo fate voi questo
corpo la b niente vorrei vorrei mangiare
anche per il frappè dalla pregiata
maturano talmente tanto che non si sa il
4 siamo giusto
siamo al round 4 risultati nei partiti
in sospeso
allora allora ora ok
vai di three ct1 trimenti cd nutrimenti
dovesse partecipare ea sports
abbiamo sicuramente il team più forte e
più preparato assolutamente sono
d'accordo ea sports tracker seneghe z è
nei game ai game non dice altro che
questo chi dice il contrario ha ragione
comunque questa cosa della pausa merenda
anche la mattina ma io la faccio frate
si no anche perché se no vengo ieri
mattina presto mai mai la faccio
colazione proprio mai
sbagliatissimo è però non non non ho
fame fame la mattina non ci stanno
la mattina però ho voglia di giocare la
stessa inscrive valhalla è questo che è
strano capitolo secco di 30 secondi di
chiusi il royal avevo già visto sai caro
che avevo consigliato dare un'occhiata
magari più avanti ai ragazzi mi sa che
dovete trovare un compagno per forza
vostro amico perché non lo potete
trovare casual o no non lo so ho visto
ragazzi che scrivevano di no però mi
sembra strano solo gente già di macabro
allora allora niente però forse c'è la
possibilità di mettere anche una sorta
di match making all'int c'è nel senso
può partecipare la gente singola e gru
parli perché forse prima c'era qualche
ragazzo che l'aveva scritto che si
poteva fare
non lo so un gelato quanto impastato
quanto impastata questa frase siamo
prima che siano malati riuniti dalla
nutella gli zuccheri sono arrivati siamo
pronti siamo pronti per sto farci ai
quarti di finale come sempre anzi round
quarto che cos'è il terzo gol ma siamo
contro quelli libro how much quanto fa
ha più bianco tra l'altro
e niente favi puoi dire che la sardegna
è meglio della bulgaria ma che cazzo
vuol dire che grazie a leonardo reazione
di quando l'ho letto non ho capito
niente spesa perdiamo questo è forte
questi ragazzi sopporti è se io poi
sapessi tirare stata un'altra pagina e
niente continua cosi sei di no si è
scazzo non ci sono importa ecco toglie
la prima di capello giusto onesto da
bosch cartellino rosso fuoco tutto
quanto perdi tu senti assoluti mettere
un persona no non ti mette proprio non
ti mette proprio mai vola a comando ti
dico le cose
poi però dall'altra parte cioè non
vedevo niente pieno
minchia buono buono l'imprendibile
imprendibile perché ero andato
sull'altro voleva fatto il passaggio di
st ora benissimo materia vale a dire
vabbè ma come giocano questi ragazzi
giocano ci sta la mossa dai proviamoci
cosa no goal di nicchia non entrare l'ha
tolta fortissimo non pensavo di storia
spingiamo che secondo me si può giocare
bravo speciale ma non è entrata mente
proprio fiato una ciofeca proprio semmai
si può giocare quest'anno e si no ma me
li fanno bene i passaggi ma spinto vado
lascerà mai vaccinati la tiratina tina
bravissimo non c entra a taci non è
entrata però non ci voglio credere
non entrata su se allora niente e allora
ripone quando entra niente
no no regata in casa no veramente dagli
steccati tutte fuori è un soffio uguale
[Risate]
allenamento anche questo vai tu ti fai
tu
marche realtà era toccato a societario
non ero io ai ragazzi
assolutamente da interferenze dts sento
anch'io speaker sono turbo non ho niente
ma [ __ ] a ma stanno attaccando
duro e questo gol ma non ci sei mi
chiaro convinto fosse in porta sono
andato perché no no no io non ero
completamente viene negato un vinto
fossili dggg allora non ero io ragazzi
non era lui non era lui confermo vado io
dai dai dico cerchiamoci se va bene
possibile che non parte mai c'è la missa
non so se è posta ci siamo incastrati
dai tranche idee succede è bravo grazie
amico mio tentato di togliere ma era
troppo difficile
e ke cavolo
sono fuori gioco io non potevo fare
nulla
non fatevi fare veramente niente c'è
potevi aspettare che c'è si aspettava il
mio tiro
magari io la sbagliavo lui non poteva
fare proprio niente
funziona bella può essere cola no
ha sbagliato volta
ora adesso
mi sono ritrovato cerchietto mia soldati
rare ho tirato veramente di a tutti no
il controllo tagliare da solo sta
arrivando 1 mai avevo visto un altro è
pensavo mi disse addosso è il meno
averlo scartato
no niente di errore mio non ci credo
canio non so cosa ho tolto qualcuno
tolto
a
questa turbo completamente togliere di
queste cose significa continua non avevo
turbo non pensavo avanti tranquillo
tranquillo onesto
adesso mi concentro all 800 per cento
non parlo neanche più vai concentrazione
maxima by ci sto e mezzo fa peccato ma
non certo in difesa non ce l'ho anche
perché quando serve aiuta a capire che
se non per fare pressing anche se
viviamo più gol fa niente non l'ho tolta
adesso dopo
niente e pressing no no meritato la
sconfitta
così subito è non posso sbagliare street
ieri quando siamo due a quattro vanno
fatti vanno fatti questi sì cosa infatti
se sbaglio ste cose
anche qua minchia per ottenerla
direttamente in porto
né dopato
meno male erano turbo vai vai prendilo
tu quello nell'angolo tenuta no
venti secondi è impossibile vai
non so manco turbo
è sbagliato ma non c'è tuttora forse
entra così a peccato peccato comunque
gigi grave che ci stava assise di questa
città è una sconfitta che ci sta nella
sconfitta che accetto finisce più
non finisce mai ok è una sconfitta che
ci sta bravi bravi ragazzi gigi ci si
aprirà dai direi che facciamo l'ultimo
l'ultimo torneo gigi ragazzo innate
facciamo l'ultimo della sua con male ci
sarebbe
sarebbe carino poter vedere anche tipo
magari che ne so chi va avanti le
partite di chi va avanti
sarebbe carino però non si può fare a
quanto ho capito il torneo finale il
torneo finale sembrano tanto portata
sino al volo la farei mai mangiato vai
vai ed easy ma io te l'avevo detto è il
fabbisogno per è il fabbisogno della di
di 2 anni 2 alla nutella
un quarto d'ora mezzo rottura
mezz'oretta questo autore mezzo
duramente bravissimo non c'è qualche
sindacato ed ho sentito a parte che ne
stavo partecipando quindi sono un pirla
finale
io ho creato il torneo non ho
partecipato ha rischiato di non entrare
io penso che il torneo finale ragazzi
the last one the last one talmente
allora ragazzi mi raccomando in fretta
perché siamo già 81 team io e noi siamo
all'ottantunesimo me non me ne accorgevo
eravamo fuori
pensate macché donazione ragazzi la
persona donazione dicono vediamo fra mi
puoi dedicare la console di materazzi
quella sì e curate leonardo scusami non
avevo visto oppure loriano anche lory il
top non l'ho visto sara ricordato il
nome così 2 euro
grazie cari è la sera se con quei sempre
quarti ed i severi ma è incredibile a
mantice la maledizione dei quarti e ci
prendiamo e ci fermiamo qua
meritatamente ci fermiamo ce ne sono
veramente più forti ce leo e leo in chat
è finita quando ti mando già broschi
quando la roba come l'ipad come stai
brodovitch
il torneo si chiama il torneo finale
ragazzi vediamo se è full e fule già
full quindi non nun se po fa ma magari
usciamo subito è quindi c'è anche questa
prima non certo magari usciamo subito ne
facciamo un altro non si sa se se sarà
così però madonna sbagliato di sposami
speriamo di no tutti quanti bella paris
ma funzionano ciò che le felpe ciao caro
purtroppo no non ti so dire neanche
perché manterremo questa situazione il
massimo fino a fine dicembre poi
piuttosto cambio store non vada
veramente un sacco di tempo e non ha
senso
la pastora gah non esiste chicken nite
di kid ha scritto su whatsapp pagine
rosa che la prima volta che vedo leo è
la prima volta che vedo leo leo con
l'account su youtube già vai un avatar
di un pollo e baci che night
non mi chiedeva giustamente la nuova
password del disco e si del ps
ragazzi non ci possiamo fare niente per
farvi entrare nel torneo anche volendo
non non potremmo grazie a jade è
astenuto non possiamo farci nulla anzi
che facciamo noi non lo possiamo non è
lo gestiamo l'open solo creare ma poi è
fa tutto l'appeal il loro hard nuovo è
ok
perché non lo sapevi no si mai scritto
amo è cambiata è diventata un'altra a me
non la posso vivere opera sì sì no no è
cambiato da quando non è più quello è
mai scritto su rocco e allora è questa
qua e questa è quella qualità di che
passano nella come vale dai bene capo
con l'artri modernità si ss fino ai casi
rilevanti channel italiani in chiaro
messi chiave si chiede stato ragazzi se
riesci a intimare ovviamente
l'irreprensibile poi poi come va bene
sto finendo di fa sta roba
però tutto a posto pagliari tornei che
invece che la password in torneo non c'è
ragazzi non per niente numeri lascia un
po common gas ma adesso dovrei
studiavano o no age domenica il giorno
del signore
questo ovviamente il medico che lo ha
detto di male
ci voleva qualcuno che osserva ancora le
tradizioni edizioni bra e cavolo un po
di rispetto essere un po di creare
samuele dipende la conosciamo
dipende solo quando usciamo tutto qua se
dura da tanto no dipende dal
presentimento della di là di come te la
senti tu adesso non ho idea fa come
sviluppa il torneo tipo a gironi come
chi si sia proprio classico torneo a
giro e mondiali in azione diretta ma se
fiat 128 non ho capito ancora sono
partecipanti o kim perché dice team però
adunate io né mi sembra un team
successivamente otto team
duecento e passa persone ma dose
decidere nel tempo di attesa tra una
partita e l'altra si sa non so perché ci
metta così tanto a partire sinceramente
si è già tutti però adesso e fu
l'immagine l'angolo di andré ciao caro
ragazzi ritorno finale sta partendo 25
secondi vediamo un po come funziona se
perderemo subito avremo turno finale due
sono stata l'ultima metterò che tv mi
piace veramente un falco la davis è
riesploso è ormai si sa è esploso mi sa
più che riesplosa la ma all'inizio
andava appena uscito mi ricordo andava
un botto o no allora amen uscito solo
gratis dc ma non appena uscito proprio
il gioco così però proprio adesso un
sacco
sì adesso dobbiamo parlare una
dimenticanza dei dati che a distanza col
di pecorella è rosa lascio concentra
vado a da fa cose che ci vediamo poi
quadrati magari dai sì sì sì ciao frate
grazie sei passato buio grazie a voi e
facciamole roba che mi è scappato
si no ma tra cui miglior a quello che
sarebbero bella ragazza prossimo a
bruschi buon torneo bella grazie laghi
sta a distanza a distanza va bene the
flame online
abbiamo ciò che ci aspetta si partecipa
siamo giallissimi franchi e diamo
andiamo bene già 1 a 0
niente ho sbagliato hanno visto sta
guardando il giallo ha detto michele
solo fra i quesiti abituarmi i colori e
viene avvolta dio ma non tira mattina
una teca lancio turba la teca lo stesso
tira regista pocho mi dispiace durare al
massimo la cazzata
mi dissocio quindi socio di arrivo io
vediamo vediamo vediamo mamma mia la di
madonna ma come giochi oggi oggi tutto
batutto fatto il contagocce dggg vamos
mattina la guarda la ladra no no perché
l'ha presa malissimo per sempre ma
[ __ ] andata sempre di mezzo di
euro
penso io io non ho visto che stavo
andando colore stava andando tutto io
stavo ti guardano che a chi magari in
fondo stavo andando via keys
interessatissimo a dei salari del
giacomo dai fratelli
no dopo il mio no è rimasta allarga non
so con quale fisica è rimasta la palla
di mazzata che completamente immobile
guarda la palla è rimasta lì ferma senza
un motivo
e agghiacciante che dicono
ma non solo qui comunque il caso va beh
ma loro volevano fare questa cosa porta
ma sicuro ma sicuro arriva uno dietro
vita oddio il volo della di mamma mia
mamma mi ha dato questo tour base di
tanta tanta tanta tanta tanta madonna
come sei migliorato grazie a ballan ha
vita propria ma infatti ai to write
va bene cosa succeda sitter partite
partita
bravo roma ha annunciato a
no che il filo ciofeca proprio
bruttissimi boom mezzo ora che entra
così non mi occupo io
be nice oggi giochiamo benissimo di
tacco
ah che bello issimo no non ci credo
ma non adesso posso farlo
come sono andato a vuoto
no sono un pirla va benissimo d'inizio
oltremare e distrutto ragazzo
madonna bravo ancora lui mamma mi
sull'angolino della porta
bravi
niente mezzo
o no basta gol di ma tanto non riesco
quindi a posto era un assist perfetti
per dire sì sì ho fatto apposta di
cogliere gli assistiti e ma io sono
onesto store ha mosso mamma mia
guardali ho sbagliato rientra dalle note
lo scalmanato così musi ma perché non
pensavo proprio che cos'è ma anche lui
se lo aspettava che noti come termale
ma
bravissimo fiat all questo qua
quello da te nato ha tentato di
toglierla in qualche modo era abbastanza
complicata la faccenda va bene
raga alcune delle squadre lo potete
cambiare quando si abbia il torneo ma
soprattutto lo potete creare nel club
cioè se avete un club potete scegliere
il colore main e cambiarlo annonese
uno scandalo fatto amministrarlo dai
basta
vabbè adesso ho capito come darti una
mano quando fa queste cose qualche cosa
secondo quando trilli ai preparati
avremo in tre cielo non devo buttarti
via gli altri
ok è gigi la prima data andata liscia
la prima è andata liscia contro l'asd ad
amos la didattica online
questo è merito del caffè mi sa e può
essere quelli leoni ammalati che gli
ammalati i cogli occhi l'altro aperto
per sbagliati in essere entrato un
pinguino e freddo mamma mia è entrato un
pinguino dentro piemonte si sa che ci
sono i pinguini piene di euro
i leoni ammalati quindi ma non solo non
andranno contro di noi no perché noi ci
siamo sfidati con un team che non vedo
ok ma siamo già in partita noi come è
possibile che non si è partita da i
gabbiani colpe comunque va beh ma fai
quello che vuoi c'è considera che a me
non ha fatto neanche il conto alla
rovescia è partito già sul kick off o
sbagliato tutto
bene ma [ __ ] io sbaglio tutto
bravo umana in ora capi prego dai ma vi
prego ma vi è chi pensa che pensavo
fosse ancora vivo l'ultimo passateli
andato via massima c'è niente niente
ducati una lama tecnova dai non è
possibile con loro in pieno il palo
tutto il tiro della tv è stata di 6 solo
da guardare c'è traccia così
proprio così i ragazzi the next ma noi è
rimasta qui e lì ma stati meno male che
lei toccata fratello mio moroso e da
solo la io avevo sognato
madonna
orribile
no
il governo
ma perché io vado su ste palle che
soggetti già perse guarda guarda ci
vediamo pure gol assurdo mannaggia
mannaggia mannaggia a me tranquillo dei
two men to motorcycle ti seguo da un
posto solo con te sei stato la fonte
della mia creatività e della mia figlia
anzi vi di tutto la dei grazie però de
dalle semine del bellissimo commento
grazie però fa molto piacere essere
fonte di divertimento e creatività
grazie però è veramente un bellissimo
messaggio ti mando un abbraccio né
gigantesco grazie mille davvero
apprezzo tantissimo
ma no ma no
ok ancora lire è no
lei
mezzo
bravissimo bravissimo che controllo per
il nice papania
ronaldinho non rim ordigno e di taccola
toccolana tocco la tocco l'ho toccata
[Applauso]
attacco io
brady palo
bravissimo
no
niente non mi dire che gol vero no
meno male meno male rapidissimo che tiro
ragazzi wow che tiro della diva da lì
ecco a posto vado io
sa che peccato
ma ora che sono veramente scarso bye di
ho fatto
ma [ __ ] sbagliato tutto va bene
giochiamo da questa partita come se
fossimo dei bronzi dai 28 secondi
vediamo di non prendere gol perché c'era
tanto odiato oppure la parata qua ma se
glielo data io che para dovevo fare
vabbè 28 secondi di camper iamoci in
difesa piuttosto che no no non mi piace
così niente non mi piace campionati in
difesa di dobbiamo giocarla se dobbiamo
perdere perdiamo
bravissimo bravissimo
cartellino rosso fuoco tutto quanto
perfino questo sarà il prossimo torneo
la prossima volta conga raga veramente
c'è nel senso sono molto contento di
giocarla con di giocare i tornei con voi
perché comunque molto [ __ ] sta cosa se
l'avesse detto stefano nava di mais con
mai scoperto proprio figlio giocare
insieme
foto dovremo trovare anzi magari anche
più giochi dove farlo
le cene sono comunque la vittoria grazie
mille di essere passata always topic un
abbraccio ok dai puntini neri già bay
convenzioni ma attenzione si continua la
nostra inesorabile scalata fino a che
non vivremo in quarti di finale voglio
non trovo il nostro team ha la discordia
e poco round 3 di adesso andiamo a fare
il round ram 3d a le tante 3d andiamo a
fare il round per noi finale
praticamente vediamo se riusciamo a re
per terminare l'angolo logo questo
quarto di finale al terzo allora ho
visto malissimo
questo il terzo round impara la vincere
poi io sono il quarto di finale e vai
no hay bellissimo bella mamma mia ma non
perdonano non perdona
oddio con 2 punti
questo sì vai vai a 10 secondi e adesso
magari con l'aumento dei punti palo a ok
ok palo gol della di chi deve andare
ragazzi angolatissima angolatissimo
la mossa di madonna
va bene che ora il gol di è andato bene
ma sembra che nata benissimo perché mi
sono messo lì apposta
cosa vi sono quattro e dove mi prendevi
di preghiera perfetta perché tanto
andavo in porto tre gol 17 secondi abbia
fatto cioè quello sì si può basta basta
segnare basta basta attraverso niente
quale adesso basta se noi che sa che se
vinta potrebbe essere lì vamos
e vabbè sono scontrati fortissimo
boh sono sempre quei ragazzi malati e la
toglie ma è bravo e tutto solo bene
perché così ribaltato lavoro tolta io
qua guarda la porta io perché sono
finiti tornano però sta dicendo hai
fatto tu vai tu vai dove tu
no ho sbagliato e sarà gol fatto
vicino ai 30 ma aspettate proprio gol
neanche io proprio così
la mossa
non ci credo che interessa tutti
analisti tutti col così farò primo
minuto 5 gol in un minuto adesso secondo
punto 5 con loro infatti insistiamo e
facciamone ancora non accomodiamoci
accomodation
vai vai vado lo faccio e si è
successivamente lo faccio o me ne pento
me ne pento
aspetto che parta veloce di là
ed ora
dopo un favore
madonna sai che tutto questo sia sei
brutta con frutto da frutto loro ricordi
ma penso che non avete mai mangiato
uniti ecco perché a te cresciuta la
barba ma perché mamma era contro queste
cose diceva che le faccio io le cose non
c'è bisogno che le sfide melandri calcio
e 16 chili di torta io allora sono
cresciuta con questo modo è capito che
faccio qualcosa
marra google cucchiaino alle 6 di
mattina
voglio iniziare bene e c'era buffon che
nella casa mi diceva questa è la vera
colazione di caffè con ragù no party
scalzi mia mamma era contraria questo
merendine non so perché non mi dispiace
nel senso non mi faceva sentire la
mancanza delle cose dolci mangiato
gruppo frutto lame che sei un altra
persona però potrebbe anche da roma a
frutto come magari non mangiavo che ne
so è appunto tutte le merendine
però guardavia pensione cioè dire questo
quello sì quello sì quello su papa non
dovevo farlo questo cosa io non sto
facendo niente
passiamo le partite che giochiamo così
oppure non giochiamo però
beh era atterrato abbastanza stortini
insomma
bravo graci accesa no
cosa è successo non lo so però insegnerò
la sto tenendo ragazzi la tengo che
stava durando 6 al 6 ore le parti abbia
fatto 9 gol
cioè no totale ci sono stati non i gol
di quadrini
di che è comunque io dovrei farmi
capoluogo mancata gol anche loro ma 90
bravo mamma mia
no no no che sfiga tra pd e ci sta ci
sta
quarto eye to eye to 3 56 secondi per
non mandare tutta rota diciamo giova
terrei
ciao avevano toccato a frate tutta tua
tutta quanta di gesù
per tutta la mappa un turbo a manetta
non faccio niente perché è un cugino ma
sì tanto voglio dire questa qua era già
partita ci siamo allora adesso possiamo
arrivare a norman 4 di hama 24 manca
ancora questa e poi l'altra ma scusami
capito e non siamo adesso andiamo a fare
ho capito adesso andiamo a fare la
partita la guardando qualche si fa
ancora si vince quella dopo che si perde
sempre
esatto contro probabilmente furia xvi
youtube perché sta vincendo 4 1 contro
lollo samu ti stimo favi e sta battendo
12 a 0 i leoni ammalati
doni e malati è che sanno apprezzare una
malata
esatto ok qui è passato bandas in qua
uno fuori ax
13 a 0 con gli ammalati a pove raggi 30
secondi di a
no ragazzi questo è l'ultimo torneo che
facciamo per oggi poi ricordatevi che
l'ultimo giovedì del mese di pomeriggio
facciamo sempre appunto la live con cioè
dove giochiamo con
con lievi con tutti e quindi
ricordatevelo oggi è un caso che non sia
di giovedì perché la di giovedì non
potevamo avevamo deve uscire un video
particolare i parà un caso che non uscì
non usciva per tutta la settimana milo
slittata domenica quindi sopra fase di
programmazione la pena perfetto
siamo contro furia xvi youtube siamo
partiti a dei meccanici sono cari hanno
distrutto gli avversari nella partita di
prima 12 a 0
no erano gli altri questi quando vinto 6
a 1 se non sbaglio
la mossa
paolo
palo a portiere battuto no
bravissimo paolo che sfiga stava detto
madonna come vogliono provare avevamo
intuito la posizione l'uno dell'altro e
la perfetta questo sono stato malissimo
rischio è niente nella mia macchina
decide di morire la zampata no
meno male ai tour notturno lo tira ma
come sei arrivato l'unico modo di cui
possa arrivare alla turbo di palo
se non segni tu non sei nessuno eh no
glory crossata ma non ci sei quindi a
fortunata catena
ok vai vai via
fu solito dire no eh sì sì di luglio
si no
no che stupido meno male che se l'è
ritoccata lascia vai vai piano dove qua
basta mai
ma dalla via dalla mia visuale non ho
capito cos'è successo
ok io avevo
d
vai tu diventi turgovia
vi si era mutato il microfono per quale
in sala per quale motivazione così mi
sarà montato a caso totalmente a caso
perché di roma perché cambiano se le
impostazioni di oviesse raga cioè vi
giuro non ha un senso non senso sta cosa
o tira non aveva negato no rifilatogli
qua alla mamma mia
non so perché si sia monta mazzarri io
non ho fatto niente vi giuro non l'ho
toccato adesso per visitarlo
ma ma caso è totalmente che il muro non
so e non elica non è legato stavolta e
ubs o schiacciamo ne sono già conclusi e
allora niente oggi proprio zio ad
avetrana vedrà forse per questo tira
aspetta fammi controllare che non stiamo
facendo una roba giusta ok l'altro un
minuto 17 perdere di un gol no
per tre di un gol non ci sto
[Applauso]
by two way to blue heaven no
io so lo so ombre dato che non sono
veramente su no no sì sì sì sì sì perché
mi sono driblato ma guarda che cacchio
ma ho fatto a perdere il controllo ha
proprio perso il controllo controllo
sono un blog
no niente
ma rischia voli gustarsela importa se no
infatti perché solo bene aiuto non posso
fare nulla
ok io comunque vado mezzo per stare bene
no ragazzi
bene bene vito andiamo lido
no dice tutto e due super ok
sì quando me sono ultra offensivo e
frate vai vai vai occhio mi chiama
demolito fortissimo ma la palla pure non
vedono dai dai dai torna torna fra ok ok
a chi lascia lascia l'ho toccata hd
lascia lascia l'hotel si parlò rotto tu
sai che io questa partita te lo giuro
sappilo io non ho fatto niente cioè non
ho fatto assolutamente niente se non
togliere microfono non ho giocato niente
hai giocato non l'ho fatto niente ora
possiamo perdere no no no si perde no
siamo arrivati fino a qua ora si perde
impapera ok allora siamo contro la vj
spero di incontrarvi dark master mario
caro lo spero anche io medi one time
no non lo so non lo so non lo so hai
capito
e tu li ling lo fonico ingrosso non solo
fonico l'inglese fonico la young la one
mirko man baldas da solo su di sé da
solo anno che ho al mirko maniche
è andata giusta
oh scusa scusa mi sembrava e trova la
vita mamma mia
eh no non l'avevo visto che arrivava
porca
niente non occorrono arriva no madonna
mi sono tolto alla fine insomma toccavo
masturba niente ma porca [ __ ] o no
scusami dio cassetto è quello di non ci
siamo capiti noi no ma mi ha mandato un
disastro succede di dei mandan pato ma
lo pensavo che andasse devo stare in
porta non ci ha capito per essere va
bene va bene così benissimo
innanzitutto come l va infatti per
diventare di bravo cioè solo per quello
il signor banda che verrà toglie
pazzesco nella difficile a togliere
notturno statuetta resisti donald on
non so come fare torte da madonna
bravissimo ripartiamo dai 28 c'è uno
ecco una dottore da brno mi sa che la
bam bam patria senza volerlo però uno
turbo mai di no bravo bravo
non ho madonna quanto l'olio ste palle
qua niente non suscita fare nulla nulla
nulla
non è vero ciao ciao raga non so io sono
due partite che non gioco io non sto
giocando potevo no ragazzi
no ragazzi sono due
io non sto giocando da due partite no
sto facendo niente di sono morto sono
finito finito io ho finito questo ma
come gioco
adesso mi stai scollegato pure joystick
no vabbè dai ragazzi ok di petosino il
cavo a niente
no ragazzi veramente ho preso dopo il
cui l'ultimo è stato veramente è come
meta la parata si sono stronzo cosa ci
posso fare io un occhio o lascia la
lasci una nicchia mi sono dovuto
togliere paolo buffalo di merda ma lo
tutte le porte riporta corro peggio
immettere volte andiamo peggio in peggio
no no è vero
ok e niente anta un chilometro uno turbo
nella turbo di fare causa della biagio
niente niente niente niente ma cosa sto
facendo come la tolgo no ragazzi
veramente vi giuro non mi dissocio la
dalle ultime due partite
io mi dissocio non sto facendo niente ma
niente è colpa mia quadra di questo la
colpa è mia e solo mia non sto facendo
niente non so perché
rip off in chat per parigi ai ragazzi ri
perotti su roche ma perché li volevo far
vincere dai venti guadagnare ad lisci
tutti e due
praga vi giuro non mi dissocio dal mio è
vabbè mi dissocio dal mio gioco
facciamo finta inutile due partite che
non avete viste e per i perotti magari
però tale da yo succede lo ha staccato
la spina non certo tutto vi sono dei
concentrati noti the map e allora allora
nichi non c'è e va beh dico io da solo
no sei disconnesso la di niente tutti
con tutto quanto abbiamo già non sto
facendo niente l'unica speranza dall'ad
senese si disconnette lui è finita fra
le tre gol da solo
no ragazzi perotti per la di pf per la
linciate egli sa che lasciata la
connessione le due aree gioco gioco il
gioco e moltre contro zero perché io
faccio che assista a lui ma non la mia
il nostro riuscito a toglierla da sei
volte non suicidato
no io sono un po stanco vuole vero però
mamma mia c'è l'abbassamento di
concentrazione totale
non so proprio il giocando fi
palesemente apposta è praticamente
sembra così eccolo là dei rapiti ho
preso un gol tanto anche questo lo
ridicolo cioè non tifa di entrare sicuro
dai dai dai dai sanitari che lo zero sui
viene sì che vengano che va in crash
hanno giocato una partita ridicola
ridicola 41 siamo ridicola dai dai dai
dai che caja non ho fatto niente soldi
by the night e scusate ragazza rischia
di soci e se si è arrivati alla finale i
pugliesi sono belve la tensione è alle
stelle e ho lasciato anche questa sì sì
sì sì sì sì
il ticino in mezzo per tutti ha
insistito vi piace il progetto insieme
essi emessi dai dai
solo che inizia a stare meglio smettere
non va infatti c'e ragione
ultimamente negli ultimi hanno giocato
io vado io so solo che il tanto la
versione beta è un attimo meglio c'era
lui va bene
e allora
precisa in mezzo ok 38 secondi frase mi
perdi due gol sospetto
no no sono un idiota che vai o no la
presa occhio un partito no ci sta ci sta
ci sta
io non sto più giocando vista era che
non lo so
ed è pure che lasciato internet a caldo
è quello poi vabbè ma ha giocato il mio
box cioè giocato un no no ma giocatori
da solo fatto un gol preso uno tra
l'altro con tre parate niente sembrava
ci sta ci sta ma non ma ora che secondo
me tra tutte le sconfitte che abbiamo
fatto questa era la meno da perdere
perché erano tra tutti secondo me più
fatti solo io che ho missato tu ma io mi
stato vice di gol ma che quali prima ho
iniziato a twittare bridal ci sta ci sta
ragazzi ho iniziato di utilitarie va
bene basta c'era bene dalla fine quando
iniziati l'italia meglio lasciar perdere
raga
vi ringrazio per aver partecipazio
voglio salutare alessandro p cgie davide
berton rotta e sabine per the nation e
per la hbo nation grazie boys un bacino
vi saluto ci vediamo martedì con la live
normale e grazie a essere passati
veramente vi voglio bene
un bacino
sugar sugar isabella anche le quali
giacomo grazie mille
i potenti cycle grazie mille dei
supporti ovviamente che ci avete dato
oggi come sempre la casa idee stupendi e
al bacino